ready to go that's like everybody so
we're ready to go now those waiting to
be let in though right good evening
everybody and welcome to the first
virtual meeting of planning committee
beam my name is Andy Crump and I will be
chairing the meeting catch this you
would have been provided with the catch
this etiquette for virtual meetings in
advance of this meeting but really I
need to reiterate the main points which
is firstly please ensure your device is
fully charged or is charging please meet
microphones were not speaking if
possible please indicate in the chat bar
if you wish to speak when invited to
address the committee please ensure your
microphone is switched on and switch off
immediately
once you've finished and pleased and
sure you have switched off or to silence
any other devices that you have might
interrupt the proceedings so we don't
want The Great Escape I will do a slight
apology in advance and we've got some
rather noisy Blackbirds outside at the
moment and the windows are shot so if
you do fo you're being heckled by these
blackbirds I will put myself on mute and
try and keep them quiet but they're yeah
so it's very unusual to be interrupted
by a blackbird at Planning Committee but
I'll do my best to keep them under
control if any member of IT if any
exciting member encounters IT problems
causing them to drop out of the virtual
meeting they should use their best
endeavors to rejoin as quickly as
possible should the member be unable to
rejoin the meeting they
we'll be deemed to have left the meeting
at that point and the meeting will
continue provided it remains court
please note that the meetings being
broadcast live and that members of the
public are able to view the proceedings
present and online with me are right yes
right present with me are the following
members of the planning committee and I
will invite them in to increase
introduce themselves
Thank You chairman and councilors if you
could just state your name and whether
you can see that your present and
whether you can see and hear the
proceedings please councillor Crump
present can hear the proceedings and see
the proceedings councillor Mills present
can hear and see proceedings Thank You
councillor fielding here and see
Thank You counselor counselor Fleming
okay so Fleming I can see and hear the
proceedings without any problem
Thank You counselor hunter Seraphin yep
I can see in here all the proceedings
yet present counselor unit counselor
Susan Jeanette here and I can hear and
see cats laquetta
careful I can hear instant proceedings
and counselor Rock counselor rock
I can see and hear proceedings thank you
very much thank you chairman everybody's
present thank you this thank you for
rectifying my slight slight aerial and
it's quite seamless until I mentioned it
and also present online with me offices
from Democratic services legal and
planning and we have a County can't or
can't be kept on highways officer with
us as well for the first item and so
thank you public speakers will be given
eight 30-second warning during their
speaking time once you're finished
speaking the committee may wish to ask
you questions so please remain in the
meeting if there are no more questions
you can leave the meeting and continue
to watch the Proceedings of our the
library
throating when planning committee
members vote could they please ensure
that they identify themselves and speak
into the microphone so that their vote
is understood clearly but other members
of the committee and also those watching
the webcast members should respond for
against or abstain we know so okay thank
you
we now move to the agenda agenda item
number 1 which is apologies have we
received any apologies no Chairman we
haven't received any polish apologist
but counselor JUnit is present
fulfilling the Liberal Democrat vacancy
for tonight's meeting thank you canister
JUnit that's most kind of you
what you're pretty sure I did right
agenda item number 2 this is disclosures
of interest to committee members have
any interest that they would like to
declare in relation to items on the
agenda I will start on this one
and then if any other coach does have
any other decorations and I can come ask
if I've missed anything that we we did
have the site visit yesterday
to dismiss afield Methodist Church
application 1903 to 1:9 ful and members
were received representations from the
ward member and the applicant at that
meeting we have also received
correspondence from the agent as well
our need to on this one initially
receive confirmation from yourselves
that you are coming to this meeting with
an open mind so our last committee set a
Democratic Services Officer to call you
name in a minute but I need you to
declare your name and whether you're
coming into this application with an
open mind if you are unable to say or
declare that you're have an open mind
on this and you've been swayed by any of
the representations I will need you to
withdraw from the item so can I ask list
to call the list on for the application
90-inch last zero three two one nine if
you are sniffing its native Hilda
Methodist Church Thank You chairman I'll
start with You chairman can't see a
crumb okay it's the Crump I I'm coming
to that application with an open mind
I thank you absolu Mills yes I'm coming
to the this meeting with an open mind on
this application
Thank You councillor fielding I'm coming
to the meeting with an open mind on both
sides thank you
councilor Flemming coach the flowing I'm
coming to the meeting with an open mind
on both applications Thank You
councillor hunter Seraphin I'm coming to
the meeting but an open mind on both
applications tonight Thank You
councillor JUnit I was unable to attend
the site meeting and I've had no emails
so I come to the meeting with an open
mind
Thank You Catherine councillor castle
huh yes good evening
I don't care is amazing having attended
the the site meeting with an open mind
I also subsequent this site meeting I
visited the other side where I was I met
the applicant who invited me into the
site but again likewise for that site I
all have application I'm coming to her
application with open mind as well
Thank You Tesla and councillor Rock I
approached this meeting to an open mind
for both applications councilor Rock
Thank You Kass Thank You chairman thank
you
obviously some some councils have
preempted the next application that
we've received correspondence for which
is the one at a bishop turn 19 / 0 3 3 4
3 if you will and I will declare that I
will be coming to that application with
an open mind I think most if not all the
other councillors have made the
declaration for both applications and if
anybody feels they do need to make a
declaration on that one please could I
let me know and indicate now no Chairman
excuse me counselor kettle hat you say
you wish to speak spoken sorry that was
before Council crumpled issue up and I
now I just want to explain that as for
the other side as well
so I've been there done up Thank You
Chancellor Mills you indicated please
yes thank you
on the second application I will go in
with an open mind yes I didn't declare
out in the first item thank you much
this cannot confirm that we've now
received declarations for both
applications from all accounts this yes
chairman I believe most yes I believe
they all said that they came to the
meeting with an open mind on both
applications Thank You mr. Nash are you
happy with that we can proceed yes yeah
please proceed thank you all right we
all know move on to the third item on
the agenda which is to confirm and sign
the minutes of the meeting held on the
4th of March 20 20 again I will need
confirmation from yourselves
that I don't wait for it against the
field and I can see you're primed there
and again I will ask the officer to call
your name and get confirmation from
yourselves whether you are happy to
agree that the meeting and meet it's or
the 4th of March or a true record I said
would you please this Thank You chairman
I'll start with you again counselor
croak catch the crumb happy to agree to
meet minutes at the 4th of March 2020
Thank You councillor Mills is happy to
agree on the minutes of the mouth March
so what date so I cats councillor
fielding happy to agree but just a place
of comment shouldn't it mean for first
and second did
Mesa do we need to propose her a
seconder for the minutes
I'm handsome
Terron are you happy to second their
cancer theory Barry thank you thank you
happy for me to carry on chairman yes
thank you
that's LeFleur meaning Kasia Fleming
happy to approve the minutes
Thank You councillor hunter Seraphin
they're happy to approve the minutes on
the 4th of March yeah that's a unit
check what's that one that I actually
was present at because I can't see the
yes you work at 19 so yes happy to say
yes to that one
Thank You councillor kettle
councillor careful yes why I proposed it
and I'm for a proposal
thank you and councillor Rock catarah
abstain I was not present to the meeting
thank you thank you chairman that's all
members for and with council rock
abstaining right yeah thank you very
much we all know move on to agenda item
4 which is application 19 slash zero
three two one now if you are and I'll
invite bunny also it's 2:35 sorry Stuart
I think you have to tell me how to say
your surname in a minute to present the
application thank you all right Thank
You chairman good evening everybody and
first one could everybody hear me okay
let's see I think
right
right Thank You chairman good evening
this proposal is seeking full Planning
Commission for the erection of a cider
extension and installation of a
mezzanine at snitterfield Methodist
Church the application site is within
the built very boundary of Smithfield
indicated by the black dots on this plan
here here we see a satellite image of
the application sites signified by a red
arrow here we can also see we are on the
corner of the Bailey Road and the green
here we have the submitted site location
plan showing the sites outlined in red
the site is washed over by the West
Midlands Greenbelt in addition it lies
within a conservation area and is also
within a designated odd and special
landscape area here we now see what is
the existing site layout plan
and next slide we can see the proposed
now I'm gonna flick a little bit in
between the two here this is now the
proposed layout plan as we see it so
existing proposed the predominant area
of extension into this church is
actually all to the rear here this
element with my cursor hopefully you can
all see that here otherwise there are
some dark areas here I can appreciate
but this is actually all changes to be
hard standing arrangements and there's a
what's termed here a baby sensory garden
there is a pram park here there is a
ramp here for buggies and wheelchairs
there is a proposal to alter the stone
work that's currently there to be
tarmacked this element here is a small
external equipment store approximately
1/2 meters in height and then there is
what's called here in mud kitchen and
forest school area play a military for
the children for the proposed nursery
this area here is currently all grass as
members would have seen yesterday this
is now proposed to be astroturfed and
there is a boundary treatment along the
red line perimeter here which I've got a
slide showing later on and this area
here to the front is proposed to be
unaltered so there are currently six
parking spaces and hard standing to the
front of tomat that's not first we
change so again existing and proposed
there's also a mature tree here that
members have seen here on site yesterday
that is proposed to be retained as are
all other landscape features on this
site we can also see some roof lights
also proposed between the existing
and proposed we can now see what is the
principle front elevation fronting the
Bailey Road here in existing form and
here we see that the post front
elevation in proposed form similarly
here we have the side elevation from the
taken from the size and again the
proposed site here here we can see
actually see the extent of the extension
illustrated here with the cursor it's
still as you can see from this top cross
sectional plan its proposed to be
approximately 600 millimeters below the
existing front Gable here and some three
meters below the ridge line of the main
roof space here we can see a similar
arrangement this time showing the rear
elevation existing here and the proposed
rear arrangement here and this element
here on the side is the bit that fronts
the green from members if you can recall
from yesterday so this is the element
that you look at from Winston the green
corner this element here shows a
proposal again showing the proposed
layouts we can see here as is detailed
that planned I can read out the text in
case it's a bit small essentially the
applicants are looking to use brick to
match the existing as you can see here
it's detailed here its traditional brick
detailing two header and sill
we can also see the ramp element here
well can also see that largely there are
other church features such as these
stained-glass windows here that are to
be the features of which the coping that
draw to be retained as you can see
between existing and proposed that's
unaltered as our features such as the
spire etc here we've now got a proposed
floor plan a ground floor plan showing
what the applicants would like to do and
here is the mezzanine elements clearly
this is proposed to be installed where
it's not there currently so a mezzanine
elements will be inside the church
it for additional floor space for use of
the stuff and the children we've now got
some photos of the site itself again
members will recall from yesterday
here we are stood up the Eastman of
gentle slope on Bailey Road looking down
looking south east would see the church
here and its spire here we see the we
are just stood in front of the church
itself stood on the east corner here we
are now looking at the part of the size
so they come and we're like okay part of
the site extension as viewed from the
green this shows what is a flea and
toilet block arrangement currently this
is proposed to be replaced by this rear
extension and one can also see part the
neighboring with your hedgerow here I've
got another photo here which details
that more deal detail so this is the
existing hedgerow that members were a
call from yesterday and here we can see
the top of the neighboring property of
Sun Bank the nearest neighboring
property to this church as a final photo
here just showing the Front's and parts
of the area of the hard standing here
whether the car parked in front of the
church members as a means of correction
as is detailed on your update sheets
this evening correspondence has been
received from a neighboring resident
regarding the separation distances and
the existing built form as is detailed
on the submitted location plan this
separation distance from the repair of
the church to some Bank is therefore
approximately 15 square meters as
opposed to the approximate measurement
of 17 that's detailed in your agenda
packs this 17 meters was measured off
the submitted site location plan however
it's come to pass that this arrangement
as you saw on site yesterday actually
goes quite close to the hedge it's
actually 15 meters notwithstanding as is
detailed on your agenda on your update
sheets officers recommendation remains
one of grant as the correction does not
alter the officers recommendation of the
impacts upon neighbor amenity overall
as is detailed in the agenda pack
members are reminded that the proposed
Children's Day Nursery is in the same
planning use class as exist in church
there for planning permission is not
actually required for this conversion to
a church positive and proactive
proactive discussions have taken place
between the applicants the districts and
Warwickshire County highways post
withdrawal of a previous application
detailed in your planning history and
submission of this application before
you this evening
as is desired by national planning
policy through these discussions
additional and amended they called it
lead highways detail has been submitted
in support this application are external
highways consul team has taken upon
himself to conduct a site visits at peak
time and to consider the impacts of the
proposal review all of the submitted
detail and he's addition to making
himself available for us this evening at
this committee we now have at our ease
technical consultation response that
offers no objection to the proposed
works and it's considered that
acceptable solution has been found in
summary this extension is found to be of
an appropriate scale and is in keeping
with the surroundings bringing a
contemporary yet sympathetic design
improvements the proposal seek to
increase the floor space of a local
business they will provide employment
services to the local and wider
community in so doing it brings it
brings a character fall in prominent
building sited in the heart of the
village back into use reversing a gentle
period of small decline as was detailed
the members site visit yesterday
chairman the recommendation is one of
grants through this application for the
reasons set out on pages 20 of your
agendas thank you Thank You Stuart
it's likely but we move on to our first
speaker please which is canceled a
quorum Harriett of snitterfield parish
council are you with us cancer Elliot
hello
I think they might be muted so they
might need to press star six to meet
themselves
cancer cancer Elliott's are you with us
hello hello is that cancer Elliott yeah
I'll bring it thank you
we come now yes thank you that was we
were looking for you yeah I think I oh
yeah don't worry so this is our first
one as well so we're all going into
you've got three minutes counselor
Elliott and if we'll give you a warning
with about 30 seconds to go and please
can you stay with us on the line for any
questions from the committee
after you but can you speak in please
far away when you're ready thank you all
right thank you
the parish council were happy to support
the previous successful application has
proved on 20th of July 18 to conserve
the Methodist Church to a three-bed
residential dwelling it was in
accordance with be e2 and b11 of the NDP
which allows for empty property be
brought back into use if the third the
existing structure needed no external
expansion under search was an occurrence
would be one maintaining local parecer
and be ten needing no significant
external modification consideration was
given to the fact that there will be a
small element of domestic personnel yer
into the garden space but it was decided
that it would have a marginal impact on
the character of the conservation area
taking into account these points
permission was granted but permitted
development rights were removed and
County highways recognizing this to be a
busy road for the village imposed a
condition to erect no gates within 7.5
metres at the near edge of the public
highway to ensure safe flow of traffic
there were only three letters of
objection two years later this firms in
direct contest for the reason that was
applied to support the a 2018
application and had sent investors
objection with only 14 letters of
support which includes your six and
filled this new application now requires
an extension it also negates the
creation of a designated also play area
in the curtilage which being constantly
used by showing throughout the day
astroturf and time--it would replace
soft landscaping and a large amount of
play equipment would be in full view far
more
we just got off from this new
application I requires an extension it
or Ness effect also no specification of
definite it outside player in the
curtilage which would be in constant
used by John throughout the day
astroturf and timer would replace soft
landscaping and a large amount of play
equipment would be in full view far more
than domestic personnel for the previous
few hours
NDP policy Yukon two specifically does
not support the development of new local
employment opportunities but they have
an unexpected impact on residential
immunity especially since the
developments in the conservation area
the cemetery of Jetsons have allowed to
wide range of valid and personal
planning issues one of these is lack of
parking position and is a key issue in
NDP v6 which states that should there
should be adequate provision for
off-road parking which is this
application does not provide both
negatives go energy is situated directly
opposite have objected and also
emphasize the existing problems with
traffic and parking in the committee
report the highway officer actually
undertook a site visit at peak times and
commented that although a significant
number of vehicles apart in the vicinity
the safe operation the highway was still
apparent I asked what you imagined safe
operation when you have the private day
nursery for sentry shorten at least 15
staff to go over the existing school in
nursery directly opposite with the total
431 showing pasta NDB policy econ 2 does
not support the demands of new local
employment opportunities where they have
an unacceptable impact on traffic
generation Littlefield Parish Council
has and always will support and
encourage local enterprise this is not
about competition with a local nursery
it's about the safety of small children
this particular site on the busy main
crossroads in the conservation area it
is totally unsuitable and is not
supported by our NDP we should take
precedence thank you thank you any
questions for the council knows yes
Thank You mr. chairman and I'd like to
ask the councillor and did you or
questions and
well it's really consultation with the
Parish Council it's all from from the
developer or the applicants not really
no no the water wasn't really all I'm
trying to remember if they actually if
they came to I can't remember them
coming to a parish council meeting to
discuss it okay are they more than one
nurseries in the well there's another
nursery which is not the profit nursery
which is directly opposite where the
Methodist is going to be developed into
it or may be developed into a nursery
and it's attached to the snitterfield
primary school that's in operation now
and they have about about 30 children
there at the moment thank you very much
thank you
and yeah any further questions for the
parish council are we sure balcony
no thank you
okay sir you're free to go but please
some stay with us oh there's the kettle
do you want to speak to the accounts
that I've just uh it's just yes please
mr. chairman counselor that there is
we've shown a slide and hopefully
Stewart will be on show us decide later
on of a design of the wall around the
the grass territories currently grassed
area yeah could you talk about the
impact of that for the committee and how
would you feel about that no at the
boundary treatment that is now on for
those as you can see it was now on
screen I'm just looking at the screen
it's that way that's going to be a brick
wall and then there's going to be
railings correct they had to put
railings that because obviously
there is a problem on this a very busy
crossroad and so in order to keep
originally they put in four cents that
wasn't see-through but they have to put
railings there because otherwise people
coming from the green turning laughs
stop Billy Road they wouldn't be
absolutely the traffic as they came out
so it's quite dangerous so that is
better but I would say it is in the
conservation area and I really do think
that apart from the fact that it's an
extremely busy main road it is in the
conservation area and therefore we think
it's not suitable we'd be happy to
support it elsewhere but not there there
is a comment about the floodplain and
the flooding that took place three or
four years ago is that what's the
methodist whole flooded at the time or
was it ready the properties
judging from the image we saw in the
beginning that the brook seems to go
underground and then come back up again
was that due to blockage of that a
course of flooding and was an official a
flooded okay so when we have had the
culvert I don't know if that was
discussed on your site visit
but the culvert brings it the water
underneath the road there I know that
the the Methodist Church was before that
was put in boarding on floodplain three
and flood paint it was improving too now
it's all it's been recategorize as
almost all but not all and insert zone
one hello and so but the problem that we
have now is that as you go up the hill
not the Bailey Road Hill but the other
way up the hill
we have a new development they're called
Upton House which is split for homes and
that has resulted with a lot of runoff
that's coming down into the middle
exactly where the mere to where the
Methodist Church is on those crossroads
and also opposite on school Road we've
had a flooding of incidents in November
which was caused by a lot of surface
runoff so there are problems in that
area we also had a concern that I don't
know if this is a planning concern that
we have had storage leaked into the
brook I think that might be to do with
the surface water but we were worried
about the Methodist Church yeah no
problem I do give a little bit of leeway
especially communication problems that
map of the area it appears that the
brook goes through next to the old pub
is that correct yes and that's the
culvert and it actually goes underneath
the road where those crossroads like
goes underneath that cottage and then it
comes out alongside on school Road and
then the water goes around there and yes
we had the flooding incident in November
19th at the culvert would solve it but
obviously all the water is now raising
down very nicely change the topic from
water to traffic you comment in on the
parish council comments in your third
response that the trix methodology is
flawed because they are not using a an
appropriate
comparison the site could you explain a
little bit more about that I think that
one through the fact that we are a
village and that the Trix was based on
using more than urban locations we can
cancel highways and I could see where
you come along with a question you'll
get in the opinion of the parish
counselor but we can also you can keep
that question when we speak offices of
points of clarification as well please
thank you
any other questions to the poorest
councillor thank you carry it okay thank
you thank you
then move on to our next speaker which
is mr. Martinson and again apologies if
I've tried to pronounce your surname
correctly are you with us mr. Martinson
you
yeah I think again they need to press
star-6 to Amith themselves can see he's
on the chat
you should get that mr. Martin song
you
hello hello I think I'm on now I'll
bring mr. mark Jensen Yeah right
you've got got three minutes sir when
you're ready my viewer will give you a
warning with 30 seconds to go and if you
could stay with us after your speech for
any questions are you are you happy with
that sir I am and there's also there are
also three slides to look at yeah yeah I
think we've got those on the screen some
delays on what I'm looking at looking at
the screen but but I thought okay the
first first screen slide says Sun Bank
house and the church is separated by
fourteen point six meters not 17 meters
yeah so yeah we have got them okay you
got three minutes far away in place okay
I start thank you my family have been
good neighbors to the church for almost
20 years our property Sun Bank is at the
top of picture a our buildings are
separated by fourteen point six meters
not 17 the point is not the meters but
the fact that the church's existing
extension is only 30 centimeters from
our boundary something known by the case
officers in 2018 in picture B you have
the proposal you seen this before with
the two-story extension the dark square
at the top that fills the space right up
to our boundary next slide please
this illustrates the unacceptable impact
on neighbors amenity and green
infrastructure in picture see is the
existing church extension you seen this
the neutral story extension Woodrum to
water along the boundary and through our
hedge it would kill a four point one
meter length of our hedge the H is 2
point 8 meter high one point seven meter
wide and planted on our side proposed
extension is too close to our boundary
too close to the hedge truth that would
not survive being cut back to give room
for the extension the proposal would
lead to further loss of green
infrastructure the Lord's view
you tree in picture D is threatened by
the plans there further trees and hands
impacted an astroturf to replace all
grass next slide please
our privacy will be impacted in picture
e the new two-story extension up to the
marker will overshadow our property from
where the photo is taken the upstairs
windows will be fully visible so the
view is directly overlooking our garden
and house the hedge will not block this
use being so close to the nursery will
mean constant noise from staff's parents
children and deliveries as it's open
every weekday all year eight to six
clubs early drop-off and late pickup at
further website this will not only
affect us but the whole of this part of
the village which is in the conservation
area the proposal contravenes 7s NDP
policies when it comes to the impact on
neighbors amenity and green
infrastructure and the unacceptable
impact on bas protected species and
birds contravene 6s NDP policies the
biodiversity impact assessment found a
bat roost in the church the report
recommends the detailed bat survey to be
done between May and August the proposed
construction works as well as the
operation of a large nursery will
disturb the bat so an application for
European protected species licensed by
the BIA report also recommends any work
to building trees or shrubs must avoid
the breeding bird season that is
February to August if granted the
further ecological works condition
should include to follow all the BIA
report recommendations and the
applications for the license by law I
hope the committee understand how this
development will have an unacceptable
impact on green infrastructure or
neighbors amenity and on bats and birds
and it contravenes the approved s and D
P where a new nursery was not identified
as being required thank you
excuse me chairman you're muted it's
probably an improvement I hear many
counselors sake sorry thank you
certainly any questions for mr. Martin
sir thank you mr. Martin go back to this
hedge that you've said that the building
of the rear wall of the extension will
result in loss of the hedge or the
impact will result in loss on the hedge
yep the if the hedge on the far side of
the hedge from your property overhangs
somebody else's property they are
entitled to trim it back to the boundary
where does mr. hedge lie does it lie
with entirely within your properties or
does it like a does the center of the
hairdryer on the boundary know it it the
center of the hedge is on our side it's
planted on our side and then it extends
in both directions is 1.7 meters wide so
deep so it he that's why I'm saying it's
too much he would cut back just to the
property border he would certainly die
it's more than 80 centimeters cut back
on it so just to clarify hi mr. chairman
it's Clara the hedge currently extends
80 centimeters into your neighbor's
property
even more AAT yes about 80 centimeters
yes thank you thank you okay thank you
again I've just been advised that these
property law rather than planning law
regarding that but yeah thanks about
only any further questions to mr.
Martinson anyone miss Martin so did I
get your surname correct right and right
thank you very much thank you apologies
for the slight delay when you go ahead
no no I problems with the new thing okay
thank you right we'll now move on to our
next speakers which are Keith Williams
and required the agent and the applicant
I've got six minutes between them if you
could indicate that you're mr. Williams
and mr. McRoy oh okay yes I'm hearing
you chair I'm president I mostly just
speaking to okay
as I say we're as you said we are going
to do a doubleheader on this and eight
will be taking about four minutes and I
will be taking the residual two minutes
at the end if it's possible sir I would
like to ask if we could leave questions
until we've both spoken yeah that's fine
you know we've been doing that anyway
yep okay thank you Thank You Katie you
ready yes I am thank you little dragons
Day Nursery is a family venture that my
husband and I have embarked on because
it's been an ambition of ours for many
years as well as being the mother of
three and qualified primary school
teacher I've worked the teacher the last
12 years including a period as mr. field
school I
always been passionate about working
with children and in particular their
early years experiences when searching
for a suitable location for our venture
we spent a lot of time researching the
area and identifying gaps in the sector
to ensure our nursing oppose the
proposal is valuable this included a
review of education and child care
reports published by Warren County
Council as you will know the need for
adequate childcare places is of growing
importance and the report identify a
shortage in the area including center
field for the need for a quality
full-time setting here I would point out
that the existing nursery in center
field only operates during school hours
and is therefore not open for extended
working hours or during the school
holidays children who attend must be
aged to are over and it's limited to 26
children per session the next closest
nurseries are in stratford-upon-avon and
Providence the former Methodist Church
is an ideal location for new nursery and
as pointed out by the planning officer
the existing building can be used
without planning permission the existing
floor space can accommodate up to fifty
six children and twelve staff we would
however like to utilize the space in a
way that ensures the smooth operation of
our nursery and enable us to create a
learning environment that will massively
benefit both of the children and the
staff the present proposal will enable
little dragons to care for up to 67
children due to the adult child ratio
requirements at full occupancy and will
employ up to 50 members of staff this
therefore equates to a net difference of
11 children and will create three more
jobs little dragons will offer quality
affordable childcare for children aged
three months through to five years
Monday to Friday all year round
excluding Christmas and bank holidays
which is standard across the industry
we will offer full-day ten hour sessions
and half-day $5 sessions our extended
opening hours from 7:30 a.m. until 6:30
p.m.
enable working parents to drop out and
collect their children after time it is
convenient for them around their working
day nurseries do not have a specific
drop-off and pickup time our school and
preschool do
just by patterns or therefore start from
7:30 a.m. with most children arriving
before 8:30 a.m. to allow their parents
time to get to work for 9 a.m. to ensure
consistency for the children we have to
pick up options half-day option which
requires collection by 1:00 p.m. and
full-day collection parents generally
collect their children on their way home
from work and so the main pickup period
usually starts around 4:30 p.m. until
6:30 p.m.
none of our peaks of the day clash with
the school rush we are particularly
looking to cater for parents living in
the village and surrounding rural area
allowing them to walk to nursery or
avoid the need to bury their children
into Stratford or elsewhere we want to
breathe new life into an existing
building and to become a valued part of
the local community to benefit the life
of the village and adds to local
amenities little dragons will create new
US employment opportunities which will
be open to local people
we aim to employ individuals with
varying levels of experience who each
have unique skills to add to our talent
pool we are keen to invest in our staff
by offering training and working
alongside apprenticeship schemes please
be sure that the safety and well-being
of our children staff and the community
is of critical importance to us and we
will take all measures to protect them I
will now hand over to Keith vision and
objectives of the District Council
include the need to strengthen town and
village communities and to improve
facilities across the district the core
strategy points the need to take
facilities closer to rural communities
snitterfield is a local service village
the very type of settlement where you
would expect enhance facilities to be
provided in need indeed the
neighbourhood plan looks to ensure local
residents have excellent local
facilities and encourages proposals
which sustain and increase education
opportunities the application site is in
the heart of the village and is the
ideal local location for the proposed
facility it is within a convenient
walking distance for most residents in
the village and well located to the
local Road
network the scheme makes use of a
redundant community building with regard
to parking the core strategy states
provision should reflect local
circumstances and have regard to the
need to promote sustainable transport
outcomes and development should not have
excessive on-site parking the
development requirements SPD states the
parking standards given in this other
starting point and each scheme should be
taken on a case-by-case basis the impact
of the proposal on the road network has
been assessed by a local and very
experienced firm of transportation
planners further they have prepared a
travel plan to encourage walking and
cycling and car sharing the county
highway Authority has concluded the
proposals are acceptable your officer
finds the proposals are supported by the
core strategy and neighborhood plan
further the officer has concluded that
the scheme is not inappropriate
developments in the Greenbelt I think
would not harm the local landscape or
heritage assets nor amenity old
neighbors and there are no other reasons
to refuse the application in all
respects this is a sustainable
development of one which should be
supported and encouraged by the district
council I ask you to grant planning
permission thank you thank you
right
questions on the to the applicant for
the agent point of clarification please
you would like to light speed
anybody kurtal in looking at the
transport assessment which is not an
insubstantial document you've identified
three sites as part of tricks assessment
why what quiz number one is why have you
limited the number of sites to three
because I I can't find it I got the Trix
handbook open on another screen that's
point number one but I believe it is
normal to have rather more than just
three secondly three you have chosen are
all suburban areas why give them that
Trix is quite clear that it's important
to have as close a comparator to the
existing zon all the sites being
examined as possible this is not any
suburban area by any stretch of
imagination it is a Bester I think the
best descriptions of neighborhood center
are is the no data in the tricks
database for neighborhood centers this
is Keith Williams I'll take that
question
firstly I have to say that the
transporter statement was produced as I
say by very experienced local
transportation planners and they have
searched the tricks database for
comparable cases as I'm sure you
appreciate councilor kettle and there
aren't exactly comparables on the tracks
database they've looked at three sites
because that is the appropriate approach
in this scenario and they've also if you
wish so
calibrated that that research by their
own assessments of the sighting
snitterfield so I do feel that the
tricks database which is clearly generic
is an appropriate measure that the three
sites are appropriate as he considering
this the basis and the no doubt you the
highway consultant sorry the highway
officer will confirm but as part of the
transfers assessments the scoping of the
report was agreed with the County
Council
thank you I'll probably come back to
later bye mate okay good good speak
catch the fielding men catch the mills
please councillor fielding here I'm
concerned about the back wall and the
closeness of it to the hedge which is
causing a problem for the neighbor is
there going to be some sort of gap left
particularly with girls cleaning gutters
and other matters in the design of the
back wall of the building once again
it's very Keith Williams obviously as
you appreciate our clients are entitled
to trim back their hedge within their
property they are not entitled to
encroach onto the neighbor's property
and the scheme will be or has been
designed and will be constructed with
those provisos in mind the gutter will
not overhang the neighbor's property the
boundary wall will be closed to boot to
the boundary and wholly within our
clients ownership therefore are you
saying there is a gap between the wall
and the building it doesn't need to
overhang it's just leaves do fall into
gutters and that hedge could you
we start to fill it up I'm not asking
whether it's ever hang it I'm just
making sure that proper maintenance can
be carried out yeah yes proper
maintenance can't be carried out in a
scheme the the wall of the extension
will be close to the boundary there will
be no gap that as I say along with every
other property that's close to a
boundary measures will be taken to
ensure that that it can be maintained
and as you'll be aware and to the party
wall act there are provisions to seek
agreement with the neighbor if necessary
to carry out maintenance works right
Thank You mr. chairman it's a question
for Kate MacLeod for me please can you
run Pass me the drop-off and pickup
times
what did you say there thrip throughout
the day are not any specific time can
you also hear me yes yes and the times
as I mentioned working from and 7:30 in
the mornings and and I know she caters
for working parents that generally start
work at nine o'clock and so most of our
children will be there isn't a set you
have to be dropped off at certain time
you will be started between the hours of
7:30 and 8:30 with most children being
in by 8:30 and then we only have to pick
up options for so our heart a take-off
option is at 1 o'clock and then the the
evening and ticket again will be with
whatever works with their parents
working patterns so generally and from
my own experience as well and pickups
usually starts from about 4:30 p.m. and
then we obviously close at 6:30 p.m. so
again there isn't a set time it's just
whenever parent
and choose to think up the children most
children usually offsite by 6 o'clock so
I think you say there's no clash with
the primary school opposite then no no
no I mean the primary school obviously
they do their registration at nine
o'clock and the gates open at night at
8:45 I used to work at that school I'm
just going to ask you though about you
you were you a teacher of that school
and we had to go veg okay thank you very
much thank you further questions
no I've got I've got one and and again
it was touched on by the presentation
from the park and so the viability of
the potential nursery I know you're
doing different hours and you're doing
different days as well if if you want to
make it viable as possible by having the
Elector you have been pupils and
students want to call them children
Holden is probably the best rice you're
talking about 60 about 67 up to 70 we
have to comply by the edge ratio so yes
even though the building has capacity to
set to 70 and working on our and Charles
and - I don't they show it will be 67
our maximum so yeah again it's just
wondering about the market research
obviously you have got some competition
across the road but it at different
times I appreciate that
and just some details about but the
market research to make sure this is a
viable potential viable business rally
as you mentioned we don't actually need
permission for it to be converted into
ownership
it's already the same classification so
the the reason why I was proposing the
extension is because we want to utilize
the space in a way that creates a free
flow environment where the children's
experiences and are not just limited to
a room and the children are encouraged
to further their learning by acting on
what stimulates them in that moment and
so that we can free flow throughout the
building and so the extension also
enables us to provide and needed
wellness facilities such as a larger
kitchen and to produce our home-cooked
meals and also and stuff free where we
want to invest in obviously stuff and
mental well-being as well can I just add
to that if I may
yes miss yeah I think it's also
important to to stress that the existing
nursery is only open and during normal
term times it's not open during the the
summer or other holidays and also Iain
takes children of age two and over
whereas the proposal would take children
from three months and in actual fact I
believe it's correct that about
twenty-one of the children that could be
catered for would be less than two years
old and so clearly at the moment those
children are not catered for in the
village thank you okay thank you
Casa kettle and yes you want to come
back in I've been advised that no moved
on from that I've seen he says I've seen
mr. Nash's comments on that it was just
a saying I didn't live this is the party
wall but no the political question was
the impact of the development on the
openness of a crossroads the idea is to
take away agree a grass area and replace
it with artificial turf or some
artificial surface
and build a wall with metal railings on
top extending to a height of 1.8 meters
which is instable tones but firing a
foot I know it doesn't say on the dark
on the on the drawing we were unable to
identify the height of the brick wall
but clearly that has quite a significant
change to the street scene could you
would like to throw any comments on that
please yes obviously there's going to be
a change but the the solution that's
been adopted and is wholly appropriate
in my view for a conservation area and
this corner site having a brick wall
which will get to Heights who ensure
that drivers have visibility over it so
it's going to be in the order of 0.6 or
0.7 of a meter with railings above which
once again is a very typical approach
for a village location you know we are
in the sense of the village here you
know it's a small piece of land attached
to to the church if smothers oh we're
talking about an important open space
within the sense of the village that
contributes to it so in my view this
wall is a know wholly appropriate
solution to providing security for
children was maintaining highway safety
right fielding Thank You councillor
fielding here can we go back please
Stuart to the plan showing layout plans
particularly the proposed one
uh when we were on site this area to the
left of the building which is only grass
I was under the impression that was
highways land when I spoke to join the
course of discussions is that highways
land or is that garden land that will be
part of the play area the the highway
consultants and the architects have
checked with County highways as to what
is part of the adopted highway and the
wall and the play area will not encroach
onto that public highway clearly there's
a sliver of land which will be retained
to aid visibility if that's the point
you are making but it certainly does not
encroach onto the public highway now I'm
not saying as encroaching I don't know
whether this is registered as highway or
whether it's registered as village green
and oh is it the purchase of their
property yes it's certainly not British
green it's I haven't got the Land
Registry titles in front of me all the
extent of the public highway I don't
know if Kate can assist but certainly
that part on the corner will not be part
of the play area if you're talking about
that sliver of land outside of the
proposed War know inside the wall I'm
talking about well inside the wall is
holy land within the ownership of the
applicants yeah seems to be but we can
also clarify that councillor filled in
with the highways officer who's here
when we've got some well points of
technical questions with offices as well
thank you castor Castle thank you
you know what we are seeing is
so that green areas which I referred
earlier on replacing with an artificial
surface we've already talked about a
flood risk on the on the road network
anyone in in the applique or
considerations application
there have been applications to tarmac
over areas for parking in front Gardens
have been rejected for the lack of any
substance scheme
now this is not parking but it is much
the same in terms of the reduction of
green soiled area soil as in we are fish
malaria what are you going to do to
ensure that the runoff would no longer
so Quinn soil will be captured prevent
it running on the pavement on therefore
on to the area immediately below on the
road I don't have an immediate answer to
your question I'm afraid certainly
however Casey that helps especially in
the area but and we've had some and
plays and outdoor play area consultants
have to look at the site and they
actually do a service now which is
porous and so it looks it's not
artificial grass it's a surface that's
designed for play areas and it's it's
porous and to avoid things like foot in
and actually be the area where the the
big three years which we were hoping to
which we want to retain and as Stuart
mentioned in his talk at the beginning
which is going to and to stay with the
and you know the natural grand as it is
now and to make our mud kitchen area
if that helps right for the question
kasib kettle we can't hear you
sorry thank you so are you saying that
the surface of that will have the same
water catchment facility as an existing
natural surface
obviously I'm not an expert in these
things and but yeah the idea is that the
children are able to play on it so that
they don't get they don't get moody for
example and that we can use it all year
round again I don't think it must be
clouded actually say it was going to
breed with the sign I think again we can
ask the officers for a technical
question as well for the view on it and
but yeah mr. Crowder's mr. Crowder's
answered the question to a best of
ability so I think we'll move on any
other questions
No thank you very much mr. Williams most
required you're free to go thank you
we'll now move on to ward member which
is catch the Richards Thank You chairman
councillor Richards yeah thank you yeah
firstly I'd like to thank you all for
coming to the site visit yesterday I
recognized during the co-ed lockdown
visiting sites has been somewhat
difficult and with 2-meter social
distancing still in place those
difficulties continue but I do feel it's
important for you to see the site for
yourselves and I along with the
residents and the parish council are
hugely grateful for both your time and
your patience in coming to see us in
assessing this application I found
policy somewhat contradictory on the one
hand our core strategy policy support
bring in redundant buildings back into
use and also encourage support for new
business ventures indeed the Smithfield
NDP does the same however such support
must also align with other policies and
shouldn't take primacy over safety
traffic and other potential impacts the
price council and the neighbors have
given their reasons for objecting to
this proposal I don't intend to repeat
their reasoning say to say that I do
support them in their thinking but I am
happy to answer questions if you have
them particularly over the flooding and
the railings in the wall at the front
where I do want to focus your attention
is to the traffic and transport impact
of the proposal
the main purpose of yesterday's
requesting yesterday site visit was to
allow you to see for yourselves the
location of the site on the main
junction of center field village facing
onto the main thoroughfare of Bailey
Road and the likely traffic safety
issues and the lack of a pope
appropriate parking provision traffic
was fairly calm at the time of our visit
but it is worth noting that in the
committee report the case officer refers
to a comment that is on paragraph 3 page
17 of your report it was made by Warrick
highways officer and that he said that a
significant number of vehicles were
parked in the vicinity this is during
his site visit despite yesterday's visit
being compared ibly quiet during a
pandemic with the school being closed
and not at a peak time we still
experienced a few issues of our own
specifically parking around the site and
some traffic conflict where we observed
a couple of blaring horns and some
questionable overtaking on the junction
outside this proposal is seeking to
introduce up to 15 staff along with up
to 50 70 children of nursery age to the
site now assuming and in my mind at the
unlikely event a three staff arriving
per car that will take up to five
parking spaces on the premises leaving
just one spot for drop-off and pickup
you Sophia stares at those spaces would
require either a reverse gear to enter
from the highway or a reverse gear to
exit onto the highway
so all those cars whether a car parking
we need to either reverse onto or off
highway at a peak time that in itself
can hardly be considered a safe maneuver
again assuming on average each car
brings two children to the nursery
that's 35 additional car movements at
drop-off and a further 35 pickup pickup
both during peak times based on my
previous assumptions to the start
movement that leaves just one parking
space available for parents dropping off
or picking up whilst all other parents
will need to either to park on the
pavement or on the street now to rewrite
all this will be happening during peak
hours peak times for carved movements
through the village and we're being
conflict with school traffic from over
the road and residents looking to go to
and from work you'll have seen for
yourselves that the level of space
simply isn't there and traffic conflicts
would cause
imaginable issues at the very center
point of the village and is simply not
sustainable you'll see also you also
note from the case of since photos we
saw earlier that show on Billy Rose
yellow school hatchings directly
opposite this site where parking is
legally not permitted our own car
parking standards those of SDC and set
out on page 8 of the applicants own
transport assessment requires one space
per one member of staff plus sufficient
space for dropping off and picking up on
that basis the parking provision for the
15 staff alone is insufficient
introduced 70 children and it falls
woefully short the transport plan relies
almost entirely on on street parking and
again you'll have seen from yourselves
during the site visit that allowing for
at a minimum 35 parent cars arriving at
peak times simply isn't it achievable
whilst every effort can be made to
encourage the use of more sustainable
routes to schools through buses car
sharing cycling walking they can only be
encouraged and cannot be enforced
particular car sharing given the leap
there is a legal requirement for
children of nursery age to use car seats
so with that and notwithstanding the
employment benefits the nursery would
bring I would ask you to consider very
carefully the impact that this
development would have both in terms of
the insufficient parking provision but
also the impact that it would have on
traffic safety both for residents but in
particular the young children that would
be attending the nursery and the school
offers it and refused the application on
those brands Thank You chairman thank
you guys Richards well within the time
any questions for the warden under place
No are we any questions are know that we
had did spend quite a bit of time at the
site visit looking at look at the Aryan
data are nothing that was extremely
beneficial and I agree with Sir
Richard's thinking everybody was making
the effort to turn up and to see it
firsthand so I was just trying to give
people some time to see councillor Mills
can you come in with your question
please yes thanks Peter
I mean you're you seem to be very okay
with parking and the and the speed of
traffic
did you I mean were you sort of standing
there all day long marking it out or you
know did you spend a lot of time or just
go there on peak times or how did you
come to this conclusion about the the
problem with picking up and speeded
traffic and parking councillor Richards
here Thank You councillor Mills and the
speed of traffic whilst the speed
through the village is another issue the
speed of traffic isn't particularly an
issue in this respect we're not
introducing particularly fast traffic or
hopefully not it's the the number of
cars and the conflicts that are likely
to be caused you'll have seen yourself
the green particularly has a lot of cars
that they're almost forced to park on
street so there's little to no space to
park there
I've spent plenty of time going through
snitterfield village itself and
invariably the it stop started up the
along the Bailey Road was cars parked on
both sides of the road sometimes even go
to parish council meetings impossible
for me to park my car nearby after Park
it around the corner and then walk a
fair amount so I have experience of that
and and I firmly believe that
introducing the level of cars that were
likely to see coming to the nursery
again particularly during peak times is
just not manageable it's not sustainable
well thank you mr. chairman thank you
Peter
thank you any further questions for the
ward member right cast the fielding I'll
I'll get about you second against the
cancer fielding I dare cancer fielding
speaking I don't know whether it's
appropriate to have a word at this
juncture with the solicitor and the Land
Registry what he doesn't quite stack up
I'm not quite certain where the new bar
where the boundary should be I'll think
about it
counsel fielding I think that needs to
be on point of clarification there no
thank you
and we did have a question from accounts
there but unfortunately he's not member
of committee so unfortunately he cannot
ask the question but there was it's very
similar to one novel was thinking about
about obviously during lockdown we've
encouraged people to walk more
sustainable transport cycle that cetera
do you know any initiatives in the area
for the safer routes to school etc to
encourage people to walk wherever
possible and I noticed did some quick
master regard in 70 people there with to
a new car approximately 35 car visits
car journeys are their end of the day so
you know what yeah just some private
police councillor Richards I think your
chair has to Richard speaking and yet
the the safer route to school is as
applies here how that would work with
the nursery I'm not really sure what I
do get reports for all of the reports I
get from residents and and this is
raising a number of times at parrot
accounts
his residents wanting to walk to the
school itself tend not to feed only
because the road I think is Bellbrook
road traffic comes through there quite
quick we are talking about central point
the central crossroads of the village
where a lot of traffic comes through and
they do come through a relatively quick
speed and there is a blind bend further
out but Billy bread we didn't get to go
and see that yesterday and parents don't
want to walk their children long there
you know what children are like they're
very difficult to keep in a straight
line they don't really observe what's
going on around them of course with
traffic moving through the speeds that
they do and the frequency that they do
people are concerned about the safety of
their children and again adding further
traffic to an already relatively busy
road and relatively busy cross road is
only going to compound that issue okay
thank you for not any further questions
No thank you transfer Richards
stay with us obviously we can call you
back for any points of technical or if
we need further information from you is
Ward member but will yes they was and
thank you for your clear and precise
presentation thank you right we will now
move on to points of clarification
before the offices and I think there's
probably a couple cancer field in do you
want to come in with your question to
the legal officer regarding yes yes I
would like to clarify that because on
the ground said if some of that land or
no can you please clarify what we were
talking about please yeah I've just sent
a message basically the current Land
Registry plan doesn't quite concur with
the site plan but it doesn't mean that
the lands the additional land that is
not at the moment registered is within
the ownership of the applicants it may
well be but I think if the committee are
mindful to grants then I think before
or plan commission would be approved
then I think they need to clarify that
additional piece of land to the LPA yep
thank you master
we'll move on to catch the mills then
cancer the rock please thanks mr.
chairman I'm just but you know for
myself here the big concern over this
distance the first distance of putting
17a now it's 14.8 from Sun Bank I'm just
concerned how close you say it's 30
centimeters from the reel of the
extension to the boundary of some Bank
which is here my ruler here picking up
what John was saying the maintenance of
it would be I would say almost
impossible without going into some Bank
garden but I can't give me definitive
illative answer as to how close to the
boundary of some Bank this will be I
mean if it is 30 centuries it's it's 30
centimeters to the middle of that hedge
or to the or to the hedge on the side of
some Bank please understand what I'm
saying yeah Thank You councillor
Stuart's fussing here I the measurement
divided off approximately 30 centimeters
been provided by mr. Munson I can't
dispute that boundary we've seen it with
our own eyes on site yesterday there is
a crows close relation to the existing
elements which is circa 30 centimeters
from the neighboring hedge there is a
then distance of approximately 14 point
7 50 metres from the existing rear of
the church to the side elevation of mr.
Madison's prophecy get some banks so
that distance itself is a proxy
only 41 7 to 15 meters and if 30
centimeters is quoted from the existing
rear to the church to the hedge I will
defer to mr. Martin on that point I
can't dispute that 30 centimeters but
there there is the rear side arrangement
from Sun Bank to the rear of the church
and the rear of what will be this
proposed extension if my mind to prove
is circa 14 point 7 to 15 meters
depending on where you measure from not
to the orientation of buildings and that
was collected okay thanks Joe and it
just we touched on the visibility or the
height of the wall I guess without
speaking of highways that was okay was
it you know to turn left you know going
past the Methodist Hall that nothing be
obscured and we would be able to see
around that corner
yes that's correct yes both myself as an
officer and a poacher highways that we
both look to that we're satisfied that's
acceptable that's one of the areas have
been improved from the previous
withdrawal application the visibility
display has been approved through the
altered boundary treatment yeah okay
thanks thanks to you thank you very much
before we gone to catch the rock mr.
Nash you indicated you want to come back
in please
Thank You Jay it was just with regard to
the repair mechanisms as to the hedge
and the gutter that's a matter for the
future owners to discuss so I would ask
that you that we don't go down that line
please okay as its as it's really their
property - okey doke
thank you catch the rock please Thank
You chairman councillor Rock and it's a
question for the planning officer and
it's about that what my call the
fallback position because I understand
this building has got the use pluses
order
that would allow it to be converted for
this sort of use without any planning
permission if the things that are
changing here is the extension on the
back and presumably the landscaping
treatment to the corner it was mentioned
earlier on in some of the presenters
there was some question and prettied
development had been removed I'm not
quite sure what the knitted development
would that building have and it's an the
numbers of children that will be
permitted if you didn't do any building
work we've been told that we could have
56 children and twelve staff bar but us
Ofsted rules but by putting this
extension we can have 67 and 15 so I'm
interested in in what it is where an
improve approving if we don't but if we
do approve this in terms of increments
we're obviously approving the extension
at the back we're improving the how the
last gaping to the side and it would
appear in an extra 11 children
but does the landscaping at the side
require permission regardless and are we
as a planning authority able to control
the number of children and members of
staff on-site Thank You councillor Oh
mayor this points like can in first
raising you're not necessarily in
chronological order you ain't raised to
put up PD rights I believe that was
raised by one of the speaker's mister
development rights were removed on the
Planning Commission for the conversion
of this to a dwelling
so that's only 2018 permission so that
related to where if the applicant wish
to implement that permission then PD
rights would be removed
I was hasten to add that that permission
while still extend was still alive if
you like it as a time period has not
been implemented or no meets notice no
conditions have been discharged no works
have been done to convert that to
admitting so were they to go down that
road PD developed PD rights would be
removed in addressing the coin point
about a fallback position
Jhin very intentionally and on purpose
you'll note the description development
actually doesn't mention the word
nursery anywhere we're not actually
assessing the merits of canvas to be
converted into it nursery as you
correctly say what we're assessing on
the merits are of the proposed extension
to the rear and the Associated
landscaping works for size that you've
touched upon and our detail on your
screen right now
that's what our so what's his offices
and and as a department and newest
members having us to decide upon any
nasty I believe you asked could the
Associated Works be done without
permission I would pretend you have to
take a view on that my feelings would be
that would be a material change to the
appearance and thereby permission we
didn't all likely be required for that
alone but obviously this application
seeks to encompass all of that under one
umbrella so you asked the question then
about what we if we were to prove what
we are proving it's it's approving the
rear extension it's approving everything
you see hopefully if you're on this
screen right now that's what's been put
forward by the applicants that's what
being asked to determine I believe you
also asked the question on a number of
children and whether or not we could
limit that I think you asked as well the
short answer is not sort of my knowledge
no I'm guided by mr. McLeod and the
applicants if they saying that the
Ofsted space standards and stuff to
children ratio necessitates a certain
number I would defer to their judgment
although that's not really a planning
consideration for for us really a
material consideration so that's Dave
Jeffery here just the planning manager I
just advise members in terms of
consideration of control of the number
of children if they reminded to grant
this it is a matter that is handled by
Ofsted Ofsted obviously consider each
building how many people are able to
work there and therefore what the child
to worker ratio is it is a good planning
principle to avoid conditioning things
which are controlled by other elements
of legislation elsewhere so I think that
that would be unnecessary for us to do
so as that would be restricted by Ofsted
in their remit right thank you for that
next speaker a next question is from
counsel kettle ghost
Thank You mr. chairman and now this is
this is for the highways officer if I
may and I got two points and both
relates to the way highways is you has
assessed the trix data firstly in the
trix guidelines which I'm sure you're
familiar with on page 16 paragraph 11.6
it says the trix recommends that users
have at least 20 surveys in the rank
order we've got three here in paragraph
four point five it says that I'm just
trying to find it the most important
data fields in terms of site selection
compatible compatibility of the main
category and subcategory location mixing
sites which are clearly incompatible and
they refer to urban and country without
public transport for example is not
generally acceptable what we've got here
and I haven't got the transport
assessment in front of me I didn't have
an earlier on it we've got a situation
where we've got a sample of three versus
the recommended number of 30 a sorry 20
and we've got an inappropriate selection
of suburban sites as
opposed to non suburban sites and if I
had it in front of me I'm just trying to
find it we have the option which tricks
are at the classifieds is a neighborhood
center this is clearly a neighborhood
center it then goes on into se users
must be very careful to abide the
selection of data which basically they
refer to predetermination by selecting
data that comes out with the right tools
side in this example we've got a sample
of three compared to us a recommended
sample of 20 and we've got a site
selection of a bourbon rather than I'm
not nothing from a neighborhood center
and we then get a warning saying don't
pre select data that helps your art
effectively helps your argument how does
were each county council justify support
for this application when the data put
forward by the applicant is clearly
contrary to the trix guidelines would
you like to comment on that yeah just by
you can you meet your microphone Cass
kettle might help and obviously tricks
isn't my specialism but transport
planning unit do have extensive
knowledge of it when the questions were
first raised over the use of of these
specific sites in relation to this
particular application or discussed it
with one of my colleagues they've gone
through the tricks database and they
couldn't find any more appropriate sites
to use so that that was where we based
our assessment it was just that we
couldn't find anything else that would
make a significant difference to the
level of the trip generation that was
that was being proposed for this
location character cattle do you
did you indicate again cast cattle now
can't hear you no Chris we've lost you
right there we are sorry it was somewhat
slow and unmuting I apologize in the
guideline it says there are over two two
and a half thousand I think two thousand
eight hundred sites I'm a bit surprised
given there are only five categories and
I'm one of them specifically is
neighborhood centers that you are saying
out of two thousand eight hundred there
are no neighbor neighborhood sites there
are only suburban sites because that
actually makes pointless having
neighborhood certain neighborhood
centers as a category if they have no
data to support it and I said the
handbook is somewhat out of date so no
doubt given tricks is used all over the
country all the time
in urban the stubborn and town center
and rural sites I'm just not convinced
and I'm sorry I'm not an expert on
tricks but this is a critical issue
about this application and the highways
a present at this meeting because of the
ward members concern about the highway
impact that you're unable to give me a
satisfactory to me what my response was
that our transport planners couldn't
find us any sites that would make a
significant difference that's not saying
that there aren't any sites that are
more relevant it was just when I've
applied those sites it didn't make a
significant difference in the outcome
well why would they prepare to accept
three when that when it recommended
number is twenty I can't answer that
question thank you right can't the
fielding
because the building are you with us yes
I'm with you just getting my D muted the
proposal as per the paperwork we had was
pure and simply for the proposal to seek
Tran admission for a two storey side and
rare extension the oldest walling and
other matters is is that part of the
application or are we just being asked
to deal with the the rare extension and
side extension to increase the capacity
for the maze maze named floor I can take
that question Thank You counselor yeah
the description development I appreciate
says rerun sighs I would perhaps it's
predominantly a rear extension clearly
there are some works in terms of on this
actual element it's the rear here in
terms of what you're being asked to
assess tonight it's it's again on this
plan is it's quite useful it's
everything you see here within the
redline boundary essentially so that
encompasses the redline boundary on the
rear extension it also encompasses the
hose installation of the mezzanine as
well which is there so that's obviously
not currently in situ that's proposed to
be added to the roof space that's also
part of your assessment but as I say
everything that you see within the
redline of this site plan here ie all
the landscaping works and associated
development to the side is also part of
this assessments can I ask another
question yes go on John
with regards to the parking there is
based on what you're saying about the
red line there is room to extend the
parking over some of that so-called play
area would that not be would they have
to put another application in if this is
not part of the application cancer field
in another another
we can we can Annie George what stood in
front of us and that's not been shown
his parking Chris might be issues
regarding with highways and visibility
so um yeah it's straight and it's like
we can't really accept that kid also
Mill's
come straight so big puncher just to add
also its appreciates not overly clear
here as his Illustrated on here also I
totally agree with what Tim has just
said we only began to assess what's
before us there is actually also a brick
wall and fencing here as well so this
hard standing is as per to then extend
further into this Greenway would
hypothetically be a different
consideration but as I say as the
chairman's probably said Baroni
assessing what's here counts the mills
thanks mr. chairman hi it's a question
for the highways officer please if he's
there are you there yes okay when you
did your traffic survey there was it
Juneau a marquetry was it during the
code the lockdown period was it before
or after the 23rd of March
um yes yes so it was well before the
yeah I just follow up on that as well
because I know when the previous speak
isn't happened to mention that I think
you were quoted or they quoted you
saying it was it was quite busy so yeah
just basically you thought the road
conditions were typical over that time
mr. poacher that was that correct yeah
the reason why I picked that time was
because that was when the the applicants
had carried out their own traffic survey
it was purely just to see if I agreed
with their findings
yeah that's Brent that's that's fine
that's that's really clear and I've
couldn't fully understand what
you use that time so yeah that's that's
pretty sensible catch the kettle please
okay Chris are you with us
sorry I'm started without muting I do
apologize to the earlier point I made in
asking a question about suds and water
retention on-site the we're seeing quite
a look at looking at the plan that we
have in front of us the proposed site
plan we're actually seeing quite a an
increase in built form on the site and
of course the additional we're told it's
not artificial grass at some other form
of surface there is nothing about water
collection water retention anywhere in
the author's report and I'm just
wondering why we haven't considered this
or have we considered it'll be Nell
discounted that's point number one
yeah just there is something in the
report on page 19 they reused the reused
and restoring the water including the
use of water boxes in Korea so that's
page 19 just before it comes in x2 it
Thank You chairman yes thank you cancel
if the question I would remind members
hasn't reflected on page 19 of this
agenda there has been some remodeling by
the Environment Agency here we are in
flood zone one with the lowest of the
three risk categories as is defined by
by national criteria matters of studs
and whatnot do come into play
potentially through large larger housing
schemes and larger commercial schemes
generally a third drainage system was
not deemed to be appropriate for this
scale of development
in what is a in flood zone one I
appreciate what the the parish chairman
raised first about local knowledge and
local flooding of the area historically
I'm not a local resident distance field
I defer to their better judgment of
previous flooding historically all I've
got to go on essentially is in
assessment terms we are with within
flood zone 1 and flood risk has been
considered in the reports and it's been
deemed to be an appropriate acceptable
proposal he put before us just one
further thing to say chair David Jeffrey
here I think through your questioning of
the applicant you heard the applicant
describe this place of this as a
permeable surface it's not currently
part of the recommendation but if
members were minded to grant and that
was critical to their consideration they
could certainly consider whether it be
appropriate to add a condition to ensure
that that surface was a permeable one
and that the details of drainage of that
area and be provided in advance of
development thank sorry chairman I would
also just ask that obviously as part of
the recommended conditions also we have
got a recommended condition for hard and
soft landscaping as well so before this
conversion before the development be
implemented where you might have to
prove we would ask for a hard and soft
landscaping plan which would detail the
exact specifications of what that
astroturf is that's not deemed necessary
at this determination stage but before
this development this extension could be
implemented the applicants would need to
provide specifications for hard and soft
landscaping and that would include the
specifications for that astroturf thank
you so you've got a supplementary kurtal
yeah no not quite a supplementary site
but it is what I looking to ask as well
the hedge and the there is there is a
document which we are required to
in the council about concern about hedge
height and light loss and this refers to
a hedge having impact either on a garden
or on a property and the minimum height
i've started the minimal how acceptable
is two meters where is hedges over two
meters and this property is going right
up against the state and therefore there
is any risk that under the document that
we are required as the local authority
to provide if the hedge height reaches
above the what's called the action hedge
height and this is a document produced
by the mccune department communities
local government the owner of that hedge
can be asked to reduce the height of the
hedge back to an acceptable height that
would clearly have a significant impact
on the neighbor if he's asked to reduce
the hedge because it fails to comply
with that document is there anything
that we could do in terms of building in
conditions that would restrict the
ability on this applicant or any future
occupier the demand the hedge is brought
back to two meters we know already
instability
thank you Thank You counselor I would
perhaps potentially likes to further
somewhere see any colleagues perhaps all
potentially in the legal department as
to whether or not we can lawfully own
legally place that as a potential
condition on my my my opinion would be
that that would be difficult I would say
to practically implement but I perhaps
will defer to you see no all I could at
length first Awards you are correct
cancer the hedge is approximately three
and a half meters high approximately
this elevation proposed here the
proposed route element is about six and
a half so there is approximately a sort
of three meter difference between the
current height and hedge and what the
proposed rear elevation would would
comprise but David I understand you're
gonna come in you if if I understand you
correctly counselor I think that you're
talking about nuisance and loss of light
caused by hedges of which are
excessively large which is dealt with by
other legislation in which case I think
I would refer you to my previous
response I think it's not reasonable or
necessary for planning conditions to
overreach and interfere if you like with
matters which are successfully
controlled by other elements of
legislation and other other arms of the
council if you like I don't know my
colleague makes an - what - be mr. Nash
yes please come in
Oh Jedi we're just basically going to
concur with Deborah Jeffrey yes it would
be it would be resolved through other
legislation and certain notices
processes etc so concur V David alright
thank you for that come back I think
it's pertinent because we've been
talking a long time about about this
application and I'm you know we've seem
to be going off we're going into
property law we're going into please let
me ask the question and then it is not
appropriate just sharing this meeting
Khosla kettle not you I'm afraid I am
asking you to make sure the question
you're coming out with is pertinent to
this application
thank you we have to consume the amenity
the impact on amenity of the neighbor
and I'm concerned that that head of that
the height at three point whatever it is
meters could it could as a result they
reduced it all I'm saying is to run they
we can do to protect immunity the
neighbor of how introduces hedge height
by a list of which might happens mr.
belt goes ahead
and I think I think the long say I think
that both mr. Nash's mr. Jeffrey I've
answered the question the fact that
there's other legislation that covers
this and it wouldn't be appropriate to
put a condition wouldn't be reasonable
to put a condition as part of this
application so I thought that question
had been answered anyway my sir would
you wanna come back on that I can add to
that I think we're trying to look at all
eventualities and I said it's it's it
would be covered by other legislation if
it became an issue and then the council
would assess that matter at the time it
doesn't apparently chair the the
proposal before members for
consideration is not for a hedge it's
for the rear extension of church and I
think members need to consider the
proposal the impact that the proposal
would have on the immunity of the
neighbor the legislation is Mesa says
well we'll deal with the hedge if and
when necessary right thank you for that
we've come through quite a few questions
there right
anybody else want to speak before we
move on to the debate
nope right thank you I'll take your
silence is agreement to move on who
would like to start sir on the debate
place
caramels praised Thank You mr. chairman
thank you I actually had three concerns
on this application one is probably
conditions actually no Astroturf Emma
Stone not eco-friendly and we just
cannot have their plastic stuff around
it's a no-no so they're going to be
putting conditions but the what I really
have concern with and which I've alluded
to before is this closeness of this
extension to the to the boundary of some
Bank
I don't know people go into a civil
matter between some Bank and the and the
applicant for this for this site but it
will doubtedly kill that hedge because
you know I I don't know they could put
the footings in I mean they'll just them
and why should the resident of some Bank
put up with that but I hear to be 2
meters out on all the distances you know
I think it's somebody trying to pull the
wool over ice somewhere and and the
other I had concern about and I know
that highways a very experienced on this
but when we when I turned up yesterday I
found it very very difficult to park I
mean it was it was a nightmare I grew up
and down and and it was not good and I
think so people do or parents go and
park their car and then going in to pick
their children up it's gonna be a
nightmare for them so I'm I have got a
problem with this mr. chairman
I really have so I'll reserve judgment
and see what everybody else has to say
Thank You mr. chairman thank you cares
the most cares the fielding you
indicated we are on the debate now
rather than a question I'm into the
debate I propose that we accept what the
planners have suggested all villages
have car parking problems
it's a regular thing that kept comes up
at parish council meetings also the fact
is that the children here are dropped
early and picked up late either side of
the school on the opposite side of the
road yes it is a problem parking and yes
I am concerned about the hedge at the
back but at the end of the day they can
have it already have got enough approval
for children to be educated there anyway
or looked after there anyway and all it
is is making it more habitable I'm in
favor of going ahead with it and I
propose we accept the officers of
recommendations ok thank you for that
cancer field Inc if you could just hold
on to that proposal for a moment I've
got counts the kettle and then
councillor Rock Thank You mr. chairman
I've got a number of concerns about this
I'm concerned about the immunity impact
on the neighbor mr. Bowden going right
up the boundary whether is a a hedge and
I completely understand where mr.
Jeffery mr. Nash are coming from saying
the hitch-hiker dislocation is different
but that does not protect the neighbor
it protects the applicant and my concern
is about protecting the neighbor so that
is something overlooked specific concern
to me the second issue is the highways
impact what is it I think I was the last
to arrive and I parked or really not
terribly safely right on the cross or
anything since nowhere else to park
when trick tricks is a national database
and it is a collection of scenarios all
across the country from neighborhood
plan from neighborhoods to town centers
to city centers to suburban areas and
it's a very reputable database and it's
developed by County Council's in the
South of England and is available for
every kind of council to use anyway
highways authority to use and other
people but if you're going to use a tool
you need to read the manual first and
the manual is quite clear and I've
quoted to you two questions down here on
that one should try and use these 22
sites and they must be appropriate to
the application being considered this
fails on both counts
so assurance from the current council
that they're happy with tricks when it
fails to comply with tricks actually
says to me that it doesn't it is not
cleared by tricks and it isn't played by
tricks then we have not got the evidence
in front of us to demonstrate them this
is unacceptable
they're going to have an acceptable
highway impact now I fully accept that
the site as it stands can become a
nursery and I think that is an excellent
use of an existing building and
therefore have the application and that
not do they need it but how'd the
application convene to change of use to
a nursery then I would support it
absolutely but its expansion taking over
almost the entire plot which is the
problem and therefore I have difficulty
on the amenity value of the non the
neighbor and I have an issue with a
Holloway's issue because I'm just not
convinced that the tricks they
represented by the applicant can be used
and I being through on a previous
occasion I've had quite lengthy
conversation for the managing director
tricks about appropriate use of their
data
an altercation I'm not convinced this is
an appropriate use therefore I cannot
support the application although I
support it in principle the idea of a
nursery going into this building but not
the expansion and I'm welcome and
actually that was like they were great
but it the additional number of pupils
will cause a an increase in the number
of vehicle movements which which I think
we should be concerned about on our
difficulty supporting it I'll listen to
a nobody else have to stay but my
inclinations will move the council knows
more than counseling
ok thanks to that I'm things I just
confirmed that the legal officer wasn't
trying to protect the uh permit
applicant so again that's that's coming
through so when we make that clear that
mr. Nash was trying to put yeah it's
pointed you over from from the plan
pointedly from the the hedge law
whatever one want to call it for a
better price
so no yeah mr. Nash was been neutral
there catched the rock Thank You mr.
chairman
that counts for the wrong first of all I
think I would like to thank Castle
riches for suggesting a site visit I
think it's particularly useful because I
find this a very finely balanced
application and the previous speaker
using this as a nursery seems it seems
entirely appropriate use what's
bothering me is the scale of the
enterprise that is proposed and the
reason I ask the questions to what the
fallback position is was for that very
reason so I've wrestled with this one I
thought about it
overnight with what we'd seen and then
as we certainly be not
to been open-minded a tallit to listen
to to what we found out however if I
think about the location in there the
impact on the community to the immediate
neighbors of an activity that's the
scale that is forecast here we have to
look at it in its totality I know we're
looking at an extension and particularly
the things at the side which I think are
in themselves their landscaping in
itself it seems to be fairly significant
I think I come down on the side that
this cause is an unacceptable impact on
residential amenity and therefore would
appear to be out with the requirements
with the enabled development plan policy
and I'm reading from page 15 and the
officers report a co2 which supports
this sort of development providing it
doesn't interfere with amenity in the
community so I've found it quite a
difficult decision and a very long and
interesting discussion we've had but I
think I wouldn't agree with cancer field
his recommendation I think I would be
voting to refuse this when we get to
that point Jim are you are you proposing
that Casterly Rock - we've got a
proposal so I can't do it yet can i
sorry chair yeah right week anybody else
wish to speak or anybody else happy -
second case the Fielding's proposal
no okay Oh Oh Walden I will second the
proposal - grunts - procreation and
should we will go through that all those
in favor of agreeing to grant this
application and this will he be making
that of this forest race yes thank you
chairman if you could just state your
name councilors and whether you vote for
against or abstain from the prom for
councillor Mills
I know refusal to this application
against Thank You councillor fielding
just holding are you with us I'll come
back to him councillor Fleming catch the
fleming against cancer dementia Seraphin
against councilors unit councillor
kettle counselor careful against
councillor up cancer a rock against his
cows cuts the fielding are you paying
customer fielding seems to have left the
meeting behind I'm sorry about that I'm
afraid I wanted to clear the chat and
went and cleared the whole thing I'm for
Thank You chairman that's three votes
for and and five votes against
right so that proposal has been defeated
so therefore I will need a somebody to
propose the reasons not to grant this
application who wants to come in on that
one okay let's Joan we suggest we refuse
it on the impact on the immunity of the
immediate neighbor and I've got the name
of that property but I'm sure they also
could help me with that thank you thank
you at some Bank that the highways
assessment whilst it has sports on the
County Council the County Council
officer was not in a position to answer
questions about how the trix assessment
had been carried out and therefore given
the site samples were all suburban from
major conurbations and not remotely
connected to a neighborhood center such
as this that the transport data was not
helpful and I think these are the point
about water runoff is something which
could have been conditioned so I don't
think that's irrelevant planning that's
a relevant matter of refusal
so mr. mr. Nash did you indicate before
we go back to Kansas mr. Nash I did
chair sorry I'm very good said about
highways refusals basically the evidence
has been provided by the applicants and
confirmed to the county but we have no
evidence basically no written evidence
to go against what's being provided at
the moment so would be in a precarious
position when it comes to if the this
you know did go to appeal what evidence
can we provide we have no evidence to go
against what has actually been provided
Thank You Chet Dave Jeffrey here in
addition to what mr. Nash has suggested
I think it's probably important for
members to also reflect on what the
county highway officer said which was
not limited only to matters relating to
tricks although he did face some
questions in that respect I think it's
important to recognize that his
assessment of the proposal is not
limited just to consideration of the
trick's data you heard him under
questioning described his site visit
during the busiest hours to to
corroborate his understanding of the
site and I think that formed
collectively the basis of his comment in
which he concluded that there wouldn't
be unacceptable impacts on the highways
network through through parking and
movements to and from this site so I
share mr. Mathers concerns don't have
evidence to refute the trix information
although counsel the kettle raises
concerns with it but we also must not
think that that's the only thing which
forms the totality of the county highway
officers expert assessment with this
proposal
you know I've gone to cancer Mills then
and then I'll come back to shortly Costa
kurtal yeah yeah thanks mr. chairman
yeah my thoughts were almost the same as
counselors the impact on the neighbor at
Sun Bank and I know Mesa was talking
about the the parking and and the
expertise of of highways but I was there
yesterday I'm parking was hell I mean we
could not I mean I I could imagine if
several buttons turned up at that time
to pick their children up they've been
nowhere to park it would cause chaos if
they try to park outside then you that
the Methodist Church what they couldn't
find this very very difficult I can't
see how it works a chairman so I'm not
sure how we could work the problem of
parking I know we've said our ways are
experts but I was there yesterday and it
was extremely difficult
Thank You mr. chair thank you care to
the most catch the rock
Cass the rock is so gentle in my
microphone of mutagenic we did can you
hit me now yes I delayed with muting
yeah I I wasn't going to refer to the
reasons highways for the reasons that
has been expressed
I believe the application is refused
because it conflicts with the Naval
development plan ACON to the earth
supports development of local employment
opportunities provided that do not
accept and residential amenities does I
also have concerns about the 1.8 liter
high railings which at that particular
location would seem to be an
inappropriate feature I know they're
gonna be on this ratings opposite but I
don't think that fits in with the street
sign he's such a compressed location so
close to the kernel therefore I would
like to refuse it on the basis of his
confident able development plan and its
effect on the street scene right
counselor kettle come back in please
Thank You mr. chairman
I completely understand missing mr.
Nash's points helpful comments about
importance of having evidence but what I
have in front of me the user manual
reduced by tricks which quite clearly
limits or strongly advises a sample size
of 20 and we have three and it's highly
recommends that many site location
matches that of the application site and
this one doesn't on all three counts
that to me is quite strong evidence and
I'm not quite sure why mr. Nash feels it
isn't evidence when you talk about
sunderland link and like I'm not the
other City is this is all of which all
three of which are major conurbations
and this is a rural
quite small settlement in the Greenbelt
and and in a what to call they devote
the Arden whatever it is area so the
evidence is all there if we choose to
use it if we don't use it then fair
enough
well I think to say the evidence is not
there and Carl Mills has already good
given the evidence about highways which
he feels is absolutely appropriate and I
would support cuts and mills in that and
I think it is really important that we
do address the concerns that counsel
Richard raised which is yeah this is a
problem with the location and highways
and when you want a major part of that
is it does not comply their youth trips
but not complied with Trixie's own user
manual that gives me a major issue and
I'm I'm sorry mr. Nash doesn't feel the
evidence of a published document by
well-known organization isn't evidence
okay and I'll just come in briefly
before I bring mr. Nash back in when I
was listening to mr. Pilcher when he was
speaking he said there were other they
chose three but they did look at other
sites as well and it wouldn't have
changed the response so I think that was
probably I might have been wrong but I
thought that was what he said so I think
by using just three as an argument
against the twenty in the trix guidance
manual I think we're on slightly thin
ice and I'm concerned about this and I'm
concerned about the whole highways issue
mr. chair of this planning committee
that if we go against the highways
recommendation we've already got other
recommendations for reviews or reasons
refusal from against the rock and coats
and mills and which don't bring in the
highways issue I think that if you do
bring in the highways issue which I
don't think you should and you'll be
over again in the puddin and I think no
I don't think it's pertinent I think
they are the experts I know that
you know forensic accountant can stir
kettle and you've been doing a lot of
work on on tricks and I know that's when
your pet subjects but I certainly think
that using the highways reasons you
mentioned I wouldn't support those at
all and I don't think I should be
included if is a reason for a refusal
mr. Nash then council knows
meister yeah i'll leave more a comment
to later I'll let Council Mills League
first I may come back okay yeah catch
the mills Thank You mr. chairman
yeah yeah you're probably you always
right aren't you mr. chairman you're
probably right not to bring our highways
into this and we we're always a bit
frightened about highways because
they're more experts than we are I still
stand by what I say that it was a
nightmare there and I really can't see
how it would work but I do take your
point
we'd probably leave that out and go with
the impact on neighbors that's what I'm
actually go on then
Thank You mr. chairman thank you impact
on neighbors and contrary to the
neighborhood development plan and it
could carry the rock could confirm that
yes mr. chairman I'd take my guidance
from page 15 of the officer's report I
think he said it's the third or fourth
paragraph down where the officers made a
judgment about that particular section
and suggesting the committee might want
to make that judgment in the opposite
direction using all the same reasoning
but coming to the opposite conclusion so
I think the word could be based on that
I mean I could read it out but I've
trying to say they can meet his time
right so I'm suggesting the proposal
does have unacceptable impact on the
residential amenity yeah thank you for
that mr. Jeffrey have you got those
those reasons yes Thank You chair and if
I understand correctly members propose
to refuse the planning application for
two reasons in fact reason one a refusal
based on the impact on the immunity of
the residents of Sun Bank through the
development which in our view is too
large and too close to their boundary
and the impacts of that that form a
conflict with policies in the name of a
plan which support the use of the
building for business purposes but on
the proviso that they preserve immunity
the other element the second reason for
refusal which I noted here from
councilor rocks comments was in respect
of econ 2 and the impact on the
residential amenity of the wider area
and the impact on the railing of the
railings and the immunity and character
of that street corner within the
conservation area
right
chairman yes I did refer to the
Neighborhood Development Plan I don't
know if you were if mr. Geoffrey Hoppe
he sounded like he was quoted in the
strategy around the NDP but it sounds
like they mesh together got that correct
yeah I think he econ too and the e10
policies of the NDP or strategy policies
which most directly correlate to those
would be policies cs9 of our core
strategy I think that they would be
formed around those and happy to agree
the final wording of the reasons for
refusal with the chair if members are
happy to do so Richard is indicated he
wants to come back with the points of
needs to come back and we are allowed to
bring them back in but it's only on a
point of clarification or accuracy so
I'm happy to bring him back in but bring
them on those two parameters please okay
sir Richards
chairman thank you sir Richards I
understand the parameters and this is a
clarification probably I'm sure
Mason ash will be able to answer and
potentially our officer from their
highways as well there's been a lot of
talk about transport can I interrupt
please it's it's a bond a clarification
from the can will bits but I need to set
I need to set the scene why I'm doing
this no no it's a point of clarification
from the councilors if they play to ask
all member
that's that's the way the rules are says
so it so we can own they can ask me a
question but I can't speak yes if
they've got a point of clarification
okay I'll leave it for members to ask me
any questions they might want to given
their concerns expressed right okay I
think we've had the to two reasons yet
on this so I people keep on crushing
messages up if anybody has any points
for counter Richards that they need
clarifying that are pertinent for this
reasons for a refusal and it needs to be
just based on information in fact
gathering I'm happy to allow those
questions now but nothing else
nope nope sorry
counts the riches they obviously were
happy with your previous clarifications
and presentation so thank you for that
right at case for fielding the Land
Registry is not pertinent now so we
won't be won't be discussing that mr.
Nath mayor well it's not it's not
perfect now so I think we do need to
move on it's not pertinent to the
current proposal and so we do need other
liz's or maces or David's assistance on
this we've had a proposal to refuse and
I believe that was counts to the rock
but I might be wrong because we've had
quite a few people putting hands up is
that is that right we had the proposal
from Council Rock and now we need a
second to chair that second to refuse
the applications for the reasons that
mr. Jeffery mentioned earlier which I
which do not include and you mentioned
two highways yeah are we are happy with
that yes mr. chairman do you light it
right now this chair Thank You chairman
kasih sudah you just state your name and
hate wish to know please cancel a krump
abstain councilor Mills cannabis
application sorry could you say that
again refused the application so your
for then full refusal yes for refuse I'm
so sorry Thank You councillor fielding
against
councilor Fleming for it
for the refusal counselor Henshaw
Seraphin
yeah I'd like to abstain now that's them
Thank You councillor JUnit sorry I
didn't hear you absolute unit against
thank you
um yeah I'm sorry I'm gonna have a
question the channel we've already had a
vote on this we just responded
the vote was previously before against
grants in the application now we've got
to we've lost the original proposal was
to grant the application which was a
bycatch the field in an our second
proposal so therefore we lost that
application that sorry that the proposal
was lost to grant the application so
therefore we have tougher proposal to
refuse the application so that's that's
what we're doing I can't see I can't see
thank you for that clarification yes and
now I'm I'm um I'm in support of the
application curfews Thank You councillor
kettle and councillor Rock I'm for
refusal Thank You chairman that's four
votes for two votes against and two
abstentions
thank you committee resolves to refuse
application number 99 0 3 2 1 9 fu AO
for the reasons mentioned and the final
wording will be assumed and agreed with
myself as chair okay mr. Jeffrey yes
that's perfectly fine chair thank you
okay thank you I suggest a small comfort
break for five minutes so we can call
the next application and see you bucket
Hoppus or as close to half a stage as
possible thank you for this and see you
shortly
list you do you need the next one or not
sorry I didn't hear
sorry's Dave pilchard do you need me for
the next one or shall I just them I
don't believe you I don't believe you
are required a nostalgia but I'd like
David Jeffery to confirm that
I think David Jeffrey isn't here anymore
I think he's probably just taking a
little comfort break perhaps if you want
a stare for a couple of minutes and then
he can calm down before we start oh
thank you
which is pop we're just gonna put your
mute door
you
at least you haven't got far to go boom
tonight have we
no man everybody thing Mitch
you
counselor kettle
I can't hear you and counsellors it
ain't your Seraphin I'm here hello we're
here
I can't hear you
what do you want they'll see what we've
returned moment I'm just making a cup of
tea no sugar
you
I thought it should be quite a quick
evening with just two applications
very quick
you
larger unjust China read well it says a
New York up
no alcohol no
you
a donor has been one came to such a
conclusion Andy
you
we can't see yours because you've got
that funny background on as soon as you
when you put it up like that it improves
your looks
are you there mr. chairman can you hear
me he's on again here
but rock will be starting very shortly
after the members the public can hear
our little session between between items
of the agenda which I think will prove
that we are human I know that sometimes
I don't always believe we are but I know
I impressed with everybody's
contribution today and apologies if I'm
coming across smartly grumpy
I'm obviously missing the common
influence of my sir on one side and mr.
Jeffrey on the other so apologies if I
am coming across marty any grumpy Mona
no I've been caught far worse cancer
kettle so I'm happy to accept that okay
I thought that was a norm it was fine
yeah that wasn't from me that was from
somebody else but I'll call you GC in
future no no sir based I just want
nobody else is listening I think the
public cannot listening
we are live harcum harcum of public
document not the evidence
I think we'll discuss this later and
members of the public can still hear our
conversations and will
you
germán you're muted this David dude you
need me for the next item or shall I um
thank you mister pill - you can leave
thank you very much thank you for your
contribution probably yes thank you very
much bye right we will now move on to
our next application which is number 19
slash 0 3 3 4 3 / ful Bishop to enhanced
the Avenue bishops and Ivan erection of
dwelling and thank you presentation I
fed everybody could just let me know
once it comes up on their screen how's
that work
thank you sire that looks good just need
to launch the presentation ok the
application that before members is for a
new two-story dwelling and associated
garage on a vacant plot adjacent to an
existing darlink known as the Shipton
house the application site is identified
by the black dot on this plan and it's
located within Stratford here the site
is outlined in red
Bishop tan house is located north east
of the application site it's within a
residential area and is bound by
dwellings to the east and on the other
side of the Avenue the Indian house is a
grade 2 listed building but that's
located further east man it's shown in
red on this plan the green dotted lines
on the plan identify some of the trees
in and around
sign here we have the proposed site plan
the existing access for the Avenue will
be used it's seen here at the bottom of
the plan here a parking and turning area
to be provided within the site as well
all this here this house is set back
from the road and it faces onto the
Avenue
it also backs on to other properties the
spinning over here and Sidley house over
there a detached garage is proposed to
the side it's perpendicular to the road
and it's adjacent to the boundary with
bishop tin house which is to the left of
the garage moving to the proposed
elevations the design of the house it's
it's similar to other properties within
the street namely Bishop bishops and
house there's single story projections
on this side and rear there will be
views of the house through the access
otherwise there's quite a lot of
screening provided by existing planting
these are the propels ground and first
little plans as you can see it's a
four-bed property that's being proposed
the slide shows the Grouch plans it's a
triple garage that's being proposed to
and it has a home office above now we'll
move on to the photographs of the site
so this image shows the Shipton house
and it's the viewers seemed from avenue
as you can see it's quite a large
detached 2-story dwelling and it's owned
by the applicant panning to the right of
the last image this is the view of the
site as seen from bishop tan house this
image is taken from from outside the
site looking down the Avenue the
application site itself is to the
of this image this photo shows the view
from within the site as you can see the
site is fairly flat the front badge keys
can be seen on the Left sorry on the
right and the head row which forms the
rear boundary is at the top of this
photo this image is taken from the site
as well and he looks towards soothly
house
on the Left where which faces the
property this is the view from the site
looking towards Bishop to the house
this photo is taken from the front of
soothly house looking at the Spinney at
the top of the photo there the boundary
hedge can be seen on the left that's the
end of the presentation is one update
for members correspondence has been
received between members and the town
councilor who supports the application
in a private capacity
there's also correspondence from the
applicant which includes an image of the
site seen from the Shipton house as well
as further comments from the Cotswolds
wildlife surveys in support of the
application Germany is recommended to
refuse this application for the reasons
set out within the officer report that
was very concise yes before we go on to
the first speaker we did mention as part
of declarations the correspondence
that's from the town councilor the
private capacity and from from the agent
as well so we have covered those but
just to really reiterate that fact and
now our first speaker is mr. Williams
Keith Williams and you've got hello mr.
Williams are you still here yes I'm
still here chairman good man and you've
got three minutes and again he could
stay with
if there's any questions for you after
your nor presentation phone away money
ready please before I start I did ask
for a photograph to be displayed as well
as the landscaping plan that was
submitted and the ground floor plan I
don't think planning officers got those
available to show as I indicate when I
go through I'll be referring to the fact
of the photograph being displayed by the
officer or the plan so hopefully the
planning officer can follow me in that
speech yeah I have those can everybody
see the photo on the screen yes but can
we can say that Sawyer thank you okay
okay thank you German for a while yes
please and far away your officer accepts
the principle of development on the Sun
news site within the urban area of the
town that the design and scale the
proposal would be in keeping with the
character of the area that the scheme
would not harm the amenities of
neighboring properties that there are no
highway or flooding issues and there are
no ecological concerns the officers
objections to the scheme are twofold the
alleged effect of development on trees
and the alleged effects of trees on
future living conditions however neither
of these matters justify refusing the
permission with regard to the first
matter
the officers concern centers on the
alleged effect of the access and
adjacent hard standing there are no
concerns about physician of the house or
garage here I refer you to the
photograph which is being displayed
which shows how large and open the site
is the scheme uses an existing vehicle
or access which has been in use for the
last 13 years further as you will see
from the landscaping plan which
hopefully will be displayed now only a
small part of the route protection areas
of three of the trees could be effective
however a qualified or the catalyst
finds no harm would be caused of these
trees on his recommendation
the proposals include use of a no dig
technique an installation of a Geo web
system
which acts to spread vehicle loads this
is a common approach and there's no
reason to believe it is an under
suitable and in this case on the second
matter we have undertaken the detailed
sunlight and daylight assessments in
accordance with BRE guidance as required
it considers the situation on the 21st
of March I wish to stress the assessment
adopt a worst case scenario in that it
assumes the trees are solid whereas the
deciduous trees on the south western
boundary are without leaves in March the
assessment shows that all relevant
windows will receive an acceptable level
of sunlight in terms of daylight it
finds some windows will receive less
than the recommended level in the
worst-case scenario in addition to the
fact that the trees will be without leaf
account needs to be taken of other
matters the VRE guidance states interior
day lighting may be improved by several
means including increase in the height
of windows making them bigger and
providing more of them and linking rooms
that is exactly what the architect has
done in this case
I ask you to study the proposed ground
floor plan is one open plan space with
seven windows plus large french doors
facing south and a large lantern window
in the roof of the Orangery
the study is a small room but has three
large windows the dining room has two
large windows and also receives light
from the hall landing and stairwell
plus a large lounging window therefore
the overall effect will be that the
rooms will receive high levels of
daylight there is no reason to resist
this sustainable development and I ask
you to grant Planning Commission thank
you
right Thank You mr. Williams right any
questions to the agent place
are y'all all happy yes happy right
Thank You mr. Williams would like to ask
oh yeah if you could use the chat it
makes it easy for me it's not coming up
on my um well you've got a thumbs up and
a one beside him That's not me looks
after me well yeah so it's just come up
on mine sorry right Chester feeling to
do with the comments from the officer on
cs5 0.5 see about the trees when we when
I work on the site inspection there were
some new trees that looked very dead
and were because of the limes were
suffering from lack of light are those
going to be retained or they're going to
come down and the proposal was to retain
the lime trees and the yew trees and the
trees to be retained as shown on the
landscaping Fran I'm aware that
certainly one of the yew trees adjacent
to the proposed access ie one of the
three trees that could be affected by a
scheme is dying back and that is
something which has reading these become
more apparent during the course of this
application so I suspect that tree in
particular would be removed and I just
follow on John I do believe this
possibility of a birch in an ash tree as
well to be coming down certainly though
there are the trees proposed as part of
the scheme to be removed within the site
certainly yes yeah okay can I can I ask
another yes cuz the fitting has Ruth
rose
the District Council done a report or
comment into the to the applicant the
the certain tree works have been carried
out on site and those are being carried
out in consultation and with the
approval of roof rose and you know she's
been content with the works that have
been carried out and I understand from
the officers report that the trees to be
removed are also acceptable to your
officers I think again tense the field
in that could be a question for the
officer as well just to yeah thank you
far as well right
any further questions for mr. Williams
right thank you very much mr. Williams
you're free to go sir Thank You chair
councillors I will move on to our next
speaker which is counselor Riley he's
the ward member cancer I do I think I
saw you earlier
good evening can you hear me I can sir
thank you very much you've got five
minutes we'll give you a warning shot
with about 30 30 seconds to go that's a
metaphorical warning shot on the road
feel free to start when you're ready
please thank you sure I'm sure that the
members of the committee will have
observed from the photographs of the
site but actually it's a very open and
light site and it's very hard to
understand how the officer has come to
the conclusion that there will be a
problem with light there and similarly
with regard to the trees and number of
which have treat reservation orders on
them the applicant has retained the
services of suitable expertise with
regard to the trees and they have foot's
proposals forward
which avoid damaging the trees and I
feel sure that the applicant is very
keen to retrain we retain the trees
they've lived on the Avenue for a number
of years and I think it's probably the
the nature of the Avenue is is what
attracted them there in the first place
and they're not minded to change it
significantly as the officer has stated
this development is not on substantial
property but it's certainly within
keeping our of the nature of the Avenue
where there are quite a lot of large
their houses already and off good
quality as the I was rather puzzled in
the report where it said I've got a
quote here is substantially the conflict
with a number of the policy client
policies but in fact there were only two
cited and those were the the tree roots
and the light and certainly I feel that
mr. Williams has addressed those so I
would urge the committee to approve this
development it's not on the Greenbelt
there are no traffic concerns it's on
the Avenue which is the private road
with closed at one end so there's no
passing traffic and what traffic there
is is very light
it's inconspicuously on its plot because
it's a large plot and it's well set back
it's an attractive building
so even if it wasn't it's hardly
noticeable so as I say I would urge the
committee to approve this application
thank you goes to the radhe any question
to the ward member
no I think you've got away quite like
that kind of Ronnie I certainly help
right thank you very much M we'll go
into the points of clarification with
office in a minute I just need to
mention something catch the field he
mentioned a site visit and I just need
to make that clear that there wasn't the
official site visit but we actually I
think these in many cancers were close
by they did undertake on their own
volition to visit the site so so it was
a personal and private site visit as
opposed to an official organized one
just so we've got that straight for the
record right we're coming up to three
hours and time is flying by I'm sure
everybody's thinking that where is that
that's 2 hours and 51 minutes gone we do
need to vote to make sure to continue
the meeting I'm happy to propose that we
carry on until we finish the meeting
after after this I'm looking for a
second date for that proposal face
agreed chairman right Thank You Kent
field in case about also or happy to
agree yes thank you I think that's I
think that's unanimous
this yes okay thank you guys to JUnit do
you want me to do a roll call chairman
no I think I've got the indication that
everybody apart from councilor Junod is
happy to carry on encounter JUnit is
abstaining so she's not either happy or
unhappy so I think that is carried that
we carry on so thank you for that thank
you I will now move on to the points of
clarification with the officer
and need points of clarification and I
being poured my question cancer fielding
then did you indicate this well okay
it's the rock
yeah Chesterfield inland counts the rock
please because of the high number of TPS
a lot along Li the line of Eid the
roadside I'm surprised there's not a
report in there from Ruth Rose or some
comment with regards to the trees and
whether they've all got a TPO on or what
exactly why they are of benefit some of
the smaller ones really shouldn't be
there and I think are coming down anyway
I think the still are eyes that so I
think counts the field in wondered what
the input of Miss Rose was on this
application please Ruth wasn't consulted
on the application she's not consulted
on any applications even if they include
T POS on site so she wasn't consulted on
this and the tpo covers the entire site
it's that's that's that's what our our
mapping system shows shows it to cover
the entire site and the last application
was in 2019 s it was fairly recent and
route has seen the site like said fairly
recently so is is aware of it to add a
little additional to that chair it's
David Jeffrey here
Ruth role within the council is not to
respond to climbing application
consultations she no mystery handles
applications for works to TPO trees and
has a number of other roles but she is
not console t on planning applications
members will be pleased to hear that
their case officers have received
training in respect of British standards
and protection of trees and so are in a
good position and to consider the
impacts of development on trees and that
is what they must have before you and
and the case officer
reviewed the previous work from 2019
regarding TPS it's not right
yeah that's right sure yeah brain thank
you for that counselor Rock well my
question
partially relates to that but first the
first thing is we received a letter
which we will declared an interest in
shortly before the committee which
includes a letter from somebody who is
apparently a tree specialist which draws
opposite conclusions to the ones that
are experts come up with are we at
liberty to take any notice of that or or
how do we weigh the the value of those
particular qualifications one versus the
other because the only reason for
refusal is the state of the trees and
the Arbor illogical consultant of the
applicants come to a different
conclusion so that's quite difficult for
us like persons isn't it I think there
may be a procedural matter because not
all councillors have received that
correspondence and I can speak to that
anyway
the view of planning offices has been
formed largely off the information
provided by the applicant and the
applicant in this meeting has spoken to
you about the potential impact of the
development on TPO trees there would be
development within the route protection
areas of tpo trees as a result of
approving this development the applicant
has proposed a range of mitigation and
no dig method which would reduce the
harm that would arise from that they
have proposed the removal of a number of
TPO trees as part of the application and
they provided a report which considers
the impact that the trees would have on
the occupiers of their new dwelling and
that concluded that in some
circumstances those rooms and windows
would not meet the be East standard
we take those elements together to
conclude the immunity of the occupant of
that dwelling would be reduced that
would potentially be harmful to the
occupant there through the loss of
immunity but also we think they would be
under pressure in some way to consider
worked to those trees to increase their
immunity and reduce the light and so to
increase the light to their dwelling and
that through those works to the tpo
trees there would be further harm
arising from approval of this
development your officers conclude that
there is harm than it is in conflict
with cs5 of our own core strategy
therefore and although there is a modest
benefit arising from the additional
dwelling that would be created through
this development we do not consider that
that benefit alone is a public benefit
it's principally a private benefit it is
not a public benefit sufficient to
outweigh the harm and potential harm to
those TPO trees and that forms the basis
of our recommendation and it's
principally formed using information
provided by the applicant thank you yeah
access to the Chatham now I notice no
cancer June its comment that she didn't
receive the letter and I believe that's
because cancer journey is acting as a
substitute but yes it is very pertinent
point and that's been covered thank you
Mills - great on this one yes question
for Zoe Zoe yeah one of the CEOs has got
to come out isn't it to get to get onto
this side is that correct this to tpo
trees that are coming out as either side
of that gate is that gate no and
those trees aren't coming out there's
incursion within the they are pas but
the trees that are coming out
I can I can bring back the presentation
up and show you which ones those are
just bear with me one second can you see
there the slide yes so it's T 16 and T
15 that are coming out and it's the axis
will be here so it's t 3 rule that will
there will be an RPA incursion undos
right but C 16 and C 15 yeah once
Bertrand once ash tree and that's good
ashen that's good TPL all of them
yeah the teepee rose across the entire
site okay so eight T 3 and T 4 are
staying there yes this thing no right
there's an incursion on the RPA from the
creation of the driveway right and so
and the other problem you had with it is
is the loss of light as now I've got
that right yes that that the trees that
T - 2 T 14 would cause a shadow so to
speak on on the Harvest Moon on the new
build is that right
are you concerned that these trees in
the front the row of lines will cause a
shadow over the new building or shade it
well to be honest that I don't think I
can specify exactly which trees it's
going to be but there's definitely an
obstruction whether it's caused and
probably more importantly by the hedge
the conifer hedge at the back there ah
so it's the hedge that you're worried
about this causing loss of light is it
like it's the closest to the house so I
would say that certainly has has an
impact
as well I can I got another slide here
so in terms of you talking about that
the shading impacts based off of the
report and planning statement provided
by the agent just formulated this is
this drawing so all of the windows that
are marked here with a red X will have
less than twenty twenty seven percent
which is which is the BRE standard
that's quite a lot of Windows there that
don't don't meet the standard and then
you can see some of those are close to
the hedge at the back they're the ones
at the front don't as well and I can
only assume that's due to the trees on
the front boundary okay I can ask this
question mr. chairman yes okay if those
windows where we can see there were
acceptable there wouldn't be a problem
with this development I think if there
was if there was enough light and the
standard was met there were all windows
that that sort of exceeded the standard
I think wouldn't it wouldn't be as much
of an issue but I think given the number
of windows that don't meet the standard
I think there will be a pressure on on
the trees insightful for them to be
either removed or cut down in the future
catch the fielding and then catch the
Catalan you know you're showing the
sorry the B are re daylight
so that's guidance that's provided BRE
is the Building Research Establishment
and we used that as guidance so it
doesn't form part of policy and it
doesn't
now right so that if you go back to the
site plan yeah just
how's that come up no yes it's this one
here which one number 15 I think Sawyer
sorry I can't see this
oh is that okay well yes it'll help
North is in is in me Direction away
going up towards the Birmingham Road so
the main loss of life would be along the
south side or the south east side so
there's not going to be a great deal of
loss of light to the back of the house
apart from any anything else once a
dining room or once a study they're not
exactly major rooms the Orangery might
suffer but I would have thought that the
main light is going to be where the lime
trees are and they are fair a distance
away from the house because they move
the house to the back of the site surely
that is not going to be a problem or are
you that concerned about the loss of
light to the house yes council fielding
I can probably speak to that we are
concerned about the loss of light to the
house that forms the reason we've
recommended refusal of the application a
concern is that among the number of
windows which don't meet this the
standard which would ordinarily be
applied is is too many the the Orangery
it forms an essential part of the living
accommodation to to this dwelling it's
it's a main habitable room alongside the
the kitchen but then there are other
rooms including the study in the dining
room with with windows which fail this
standard as I say I think that they're
the BR eak standards are widely used and
widely accepted as an appropriate
standard to apply when considering the
impact of trees on daylight within
dwellings that is the standard which the
applicant chose to consider his
application against and he finds that
there's a number of windows that that
can't meet that standard every seeks
approval regardless
till you not the hedge along the back
belongs to him doesn't it if that is so
could he not reduce the height of that
hedge well at the moment and that's that
actually provides screening of the house
of the site and will do provide
screening of the house as well so I I
would think they'd want to maintain that
height to retain privacy especially as
they are views of the site from the
property at the back sudenly house
okay help you that kind of hidden cash
cattle
councillor Mills Thank You mr. chair
sorry if you recommend refusal on the
basis of cs9 but you on page 30 you say
it is acceptable in in accordance with
CS 9 on the fourth paragraph from the
top and the gear page 27 on the second
paragraph up and the bottom you say it's
acceptable in in line with policy cs9 so
I'm just trying to resolve this conflict
we've got two paragraphs way of saying
it complies the CS nine and one
paragraph where a particular aspect
doesn't comply but if we put another mix
two versus one results in one winning
you want to just come back to me on that
and then I'd like to follow up if I may
mr. chairman sorry sorry about the diss
the discrepancy there I think what I'm
trying to say in the report is that
there's no harm on the residential
immunity of the neighbors from the
proposal however due to the standards
like standards not being met
I consider that they is going to be some
harm to the immunity of the future
occupiers so in that respect there is a
conflict then you rehearsal cs5 and is
being completely to s5 but there
elsewhere in the report you support use
core structure poses two four six I've
already referred to nine fifteen sixteen
twenty six and be2 would support the
application so it seems to me that we're
using the refusal or the failure to
comply with two policies one of which is
both ways but there are about one two
three four five six seven
seven core structure policies and one
make them
MDP Potsie b2 which would support the
application only if we talk about
planning balance rather than you know
failure to comply with one means refusal
I'm not sure that there's a question
here however um I think I'd just like to
offer a little guidance if I make the
the development plan provides policies
we have to consider all those policies
as a whole now the application may well
comply with a range of policies however
it clearly conflicts with other policies
we've identified those conflicts and
they form the basis of a recommendation
for refusal the way planning works and
the way in which this Authority uses it
as an always will be I suppose to
consider whether there is a conflict
with any of the policies in the plan and
make their recommendations on the basis
of that compliance with other policies
does not forgive it for conflicting with
another council nails please thanks Jim
and so it is our TPO I think you always
a showstopper I mean if there's a TPO
nothing could be built without TPO is I
mean are they are they sacrosanct can
they be pulled down not all right the
whole purpose of the tpo is to protect
those trees from being compromised and
whether that's the result of development
I think he knew you need to consider the
impacts on the tpo and there can be
cases where there isn't going to be any
impact or they'll be limited impact but
I think in this case given that that
pío covers the entire site and given
given the quality of the trees I think
that in this case that's a that's enough
of a reason for us to be concerned about
the harm to them yeah I think I think I
can offer something here we may be a bit
of a divergent
the TTP Oh trees is not always a show we
know that there's a small percentage of
tpo trees which are damaged not very
healthy and their removal is good our
cultural practice so long development
sites sometimes we allow for them to be
removed or the trees offer amenity they
improve the quality and character of the
area and they are protected both that's
Tico trees and through our policies of
the development plan where those are
proposed to be potentially damaged or
removed that is unacceptable unless
there are public benefits arising from
the proposal that outweighed those
considerations or the material
considerations that the outweigh those
harms identified in this case I think
we've we've got a proposal that achieves
a single dwelling in our view it would
be somewhat harmful to a number of TPO
trees and we consider that the benefit
of the single dwelling does not outweigh
the potential harm through the through
the loss of trees and potential future
loss of trees that could arise in
reaching this conclusion we're mindful
that we have a strong five-year housing
land supply and so the benefit of new
housing is considered in that context at
the current time so Danny weed are we
saying that nothing can be built on this
side because of the TP OS I mean nothing
I mean we say that there isn't any way
gonna be but so let's just have to stay
as a site okay cuz I'm not sure that is
what we're saying we're saying
fails because it would lead to pressure
on those TPO trees from the loss of
light to Windows and the lack of
daylight to Windows of that property the
applicant may wish to consider how they
could redesign the property and they've
talked about different window designs
and shapes and so on in this meeting
however that is not the proposal before
us we must determine what we have before
us on its merits and determine future
applications separately on their merits
okay yep thank you for that I think I
was that comment as well but everything
to change the fielding
Joan are you with us unmute in law
recommendations you refer to such an
application is consider contrary to the
requirements of cs5 C which basically
doesn't refer to loss of light it all
refers to for us to lead any loss or
damage that may rather protect the
quality of ancient wood and semi natural
woodland it doesn't really refer to
anything to do with trees with T Bo zone
it's basically to do with Woodlands
landscaping and design schemes my I
don't quite know why you're using that
the tanks job entails light thanks John
that's unfortunately what you've said
they're slightly incorrect cs5 C point
three says that the design and layout of
development schemes and other projects
etc shall incorporate rupees in a manner
that is appropriate to the nature of the
site including the use of native species
there are other elements of that policy
which support our reason for refusal
cache the cattle are you are you okay to
speak got some some guidance I assume
its core strategy yes I thought you
might have gone to get that doesn't
follow on home council buildings looking
at the tree report and I thought I know
cohort preferred earlier on to the
document which Calistoga unit hasn't
seen from cultural wildlife that is an
organization which is regularly reported
on behalf of that the applications can I
just confirm mr. Jeffrey that they're a
recognized organization we received
their reports from time to time yeah
yeah so they're not a one-off
out-of-the-blue organization
in their report they identified that the
ashtray and I'm just trying to find it
is poor with Deadwood appearing and
canopy filling so if it's not exactly a
good condition tree that's 15 and 16 the
Silver Birch is in fair condition so
we're losing one tree which is in poor
condition and I do think I think of
number applications in my site where
there has been substantial removal of
tpo trees so I'm slightly concerned that
we're doing it concerned about loss and
one TPO tree which is described as poor
and one which is fair
do you want to sort of come back on that
because those many trees were losing
aren't they those are the only trees we
lose immediately upon development I
think that's probably a concern that
there's potential of harm arising to
trees through pressure to remove them
following development because the
amenity of the future arctic winds would
be harmed there is also an element of
development within the root protection
areas trees which we would be concerned
that that's not beneficial for the tree
in the long term and as you say one of
those trees that to be removed is of
fair condition although obviously it's
not ringing endorsement I recognize that
however as I say we're in an area where
these tree Utah are TDP owed they offer
amenity and improve the character of the
area and of course strategy sets out
that we should preserve those for that
benefit their harm of the loss of those
trees needs to be weighed against any
other public benefit members might be
able to identify however offices
recommend a refusal yeah in relation to
the and I'm not quite sure so hopefully
something can help you with this the
letter that we have received from
Quattro Wildlife said that the structure
of the area is what we have norm will be
load will be designed to be load-bearing
to minimize the impact on the root
structure of the remaining trees name of
the lime trees which along the sort of
facade of the botton of the plot do you
have a comment on whether that is a
feasible I mean a peaceful solution to
have a load-bearing surface to prevent
damage to the root structure
I guess only to say that we have
approved that elsewhere and it has been
used successfully elsewhere what we
usually do where we intend to approve
schemes with that incorporated is to
secure those details by condition
however in this case because we feel the
benefit of the development does not
outweigh the potential harm we've
recommended the fuse on the Junod please
I just want to check that as well as the
core strategy and what it says about
trees we also have a treat management
protocol as part of the council's
policies I can't see why we're we're
having so much of a debate about this we
it's quite here it seems to be quickly I
suppose I should be asking a question at
this stage that we have pretty
sufficient protection for trees within
both our core strategy and our tree
management protocol we have sufficient
standards on on daylight and we do not
appear to be taking these into
consideration
can I just clarify that counts the
Ginyard that we as count there is on
this committee and not taking those into
question
you didn't mean the officers there
I was reflecting the discussion not the
officers advice I thought you said that
I just just just wanted to clarify that
and didn't want to put words in your
mouth and I don't think I have kept mr.
Nash you've got a question
no chair just going to Milan councils
that sponge of clarification not when
we're not in debate yes oh good
that's it sure will pick an option right
canister fielding you've got a question
can me again follow the gardens from
he's just telling me off
I'm sad that we can't question can we
don't get the question please yes Ruth
rose because I believe that we're over
egging the business over the trees
how much study have we done with regards
to the length of the roots from those
lime trees across the site I think we've
had I think has touched on that before I
think we've had some reassurance both
from mr. Jeffrey and so yeah that the
case officer
sorry I'll keep on being presumptive
there so yeah the case officer about
their competence their training and the
fact that we've touched the TPO was
looked at in 2009
sorry 2019 if it's been 2009 I would
have questioned that so I do apologize
that's me so I think that I think we can
move on I think we've answered that
question and we're just going around in
circles
and I think at 23 minutes pass no I
think we do need to move on now and get
on to the bike because we are going from
questions to the officers and I think
we're very close to wearing into the
debate so I'd rather we did the debate
formally rather than have a sort of semi
technical questions with offices and
bringing the debate in as well so unless
anybody's got any other further
technical questions two officers and I
mean questions not comments I'm
proposing that we move on to points of
sorry the debate itself
we we're happy to move on
yes I boot yeah brilliant
right so we move on to the bytes who do
want to started we've obviously touched
on it quite a few times
catch the Junod please thank you the
officer has quite clearly stated that
there are problems with the BRE
standards the Sun is for daylight this
application cannot meet these standards
if allowed it would be quite a
considerable chance that in the future
there would be an application or several
applications for tree removal which
would be against our policy both our
core strategy and a tree tree management
protocol as well as our support for
biodiversity therefore I cannot support
this application thanks you can see
JUnit now on to Chris kettle kettle
please
thank you it's REI pricing for my mute
or unmute is it well I have always give
great credence to counselor unit and
environmental credentials and it's rare
I find myself in conflict with her but I
am in conflict here if I go through the
committee report and I've always been
taught it is a matter of planning
violence not a matter of one failure to
meet one policy effectively vetoes any
application in my own ward I was hugely
concerned about the removal of a huge
number of TPM trees on quite a large
site and I can remember another
application in award support it was
where again a benefit of housing was
seen as - we lost GPO trees it happens
we lose TPO trees and I've been on the
site and I've looked at the ash tree and
I as somebody who has planted thousands
of trees in my life and cared for them
and maintained trees the ash tree the
ash tree is known as a warrior it should
weed it is everywhere it is not a
classic tree and here it is very close
to properties it won't be without
dieback the longevity of ash trees is
very very limited
so I give no value to the ash tree I'm
afraid in my personal opinion um that
sort of virtue it's the other tree to be
removed I'm very fond of silver birches
but they're not it's a fair condition
tree it's not in a good condition tree
but with the important thing is we're
retaining the avenue of trees that runs
along not only the avenue is accessing
the site but having gone the 90 degrees
as mr. chairman you and a number of
other councillors including myself
yesterday
the Avenue continued all the way down
and all those trees have been retained
despite very mad a very considerable
development all the way along and if you
look at the Avenue a considerable number
of those houses have been built and
leads into the north of those trees in
the avenue which would restrict the
light going through their windows so
when I look at the policies and I
mentioned them earlier on which are
supported with the application and at
the end of the day we are the council
should in our course I can we say should
be in support of all sustainable
development what we're saying my view is
the failure to keep two trees one of
poor of one of their quality is actually
being pushed in the balance against
policy news two four six nine fifteen
sixteen and twenty six it is a balance
it is not failure to meet one
application results in the veto of a of
an application so I'm sorry canal
subdued on this one I'm apt in
supporting this application it is a
scruffy bit of ground something needs to
happen there and here we have a
sympathetic development that complies
with a number of our policies a
development that is designed to fit in
with its immediate neighbor the rather
magnificent Bishop some house and I
think it would be it is very sympathetic
to its setting so I would absolutely be
a not making opposed when you listen to
other people first but I minded that it
is a good application on one that I'd be
happy to do support but I'm not gonna
board yet
right icon next week next speakers tense
the fielding then we've got counselor
rock and trance the mills
I was about to second counts
kettles comments I've been I was
involved in forestry for about 15 years
and some of those limes I would love to
know the age of them but I think they've
almost goes into their sell-by date and
therefore are probably nearer in the
position to coming down than anything
else the house I in my book is cs5 five
was the other matter quoted and
landscaping and character and also CSS I
think 15 to do with distinctiveness this
house has got a a very distinctive look
about its in keeping with the other
large houses in the area I think it
would be that site would be ruined if a
smaller property was put on it in
relation to bishops and house and so I
am in favor of granting Planning
Commission in this instance
thank you next the fielding our next
Peter is catch the rock please Thank You
chairman I've done a paraphrase what a
catch the kettle said I've got a high
regard that counts the kettles
environmental credentials on this
occasion I have to disagree with him and
I'm trying to agree with cancer the
Jeunet I'm slightly uneasy that we've
got a report from apparently a highly
qualified are illogical consultant that
seems to think we can take measures to
ameliorate the damage to the trees but
I'm also inclined to go along with the
officers recommendation and refuse the
application if nothing else on the
precautionary principle because I do
think pressures would be brought to bear
to cut down lose or damage the trees so
I don't think it's just a question of
one or two I think that the pressures
would come along because of the shading
of those trees in the future so I'm in
favor of going along with the officers
recommendation
you can stir up cancer mills thanks mr.
chairman I'm going backwards and
forwards on this in my mind refusal or
grants I still quite can't credit and
the size of these windows if they were
made bigger then we wouldn't have a
problem because they let the light in
and we do seem to be all the build I
seem to be quite away from the limes
yeah the officers are so expert in what
they're doing and I find it very very
difficult to disagree them and lots of
things so at the moment mr. chairman I
don't know where to go on this I don't
speak learning rubbish at the moment but
it seems to me if we had the architect
to give them larger windows we wouldn't
be where we are now
mr. chairman so can i think on that one
Sano's I would never describe you
talking rubbish you speak from the heart
and with passion and it's a genuine
concern about planning so I always value
your opinion and disagree you're talking
rubbish so if anybody can say hunter
Seraphin I can just you I can just see
you in the corn and your party the
obscure yeah Thank You chair after most
site visits I gave it some thought on
this application it seems far enough
away from the lime trees to me as
regards to taking down two trees at the
back
I'm sure the owner could always possibly
plant a couple more trees to replace
those in a different place but I can't
see anything wrong with this application
the building looks beautiful it's far
enough back it's not interfering with
anything so I would support the
application right before we get there
some proposals and I would like to put
some points in but I'm happy to defer to
somebody
if I want to speak first
No right yeah an ex-colleague on the
Planning Committee counts the Williams
used to say it was good but not quite
right so therefore it was wrong and I
work on working on that principle with
this one we've got a strong five-year
house in Nunn surprise there's no
pressing need for properties and I've
got concerned about the future
protection of the tpo trees because of
the potential lack of light to those
windows certainly I think the site has
potential for a property and I think the
property would potentially make that
site much more aesthetically pleasing so
it's definitely got potential and but I
still think there's many questions
doubts in the back of my mind that might
move to say that I think we should
refuse this application and wait for
another revised application for a house
on this site that answers some of the
questions some of the dates that we have
so that I if I came to a vote I would be
going with the offices recommendation to
refuse this application
right after the embryo has chosen to
speak I'm looking for Peter you you
waving to me it couldn't come back in
yeah as as a question of light as winter
approaches these lime trees are
deciduous so there will be no leaves on
them so there won't be any real loss of
light during the winter that's all I can
say on that yeah no problem no that's a
fair point yeah definitely
that's a fair point so right um now
looking for somebody to propose either
refuse or grunt case the kettle I'd like
to propose that we got promotion on this
albeit with ensuring that proper
appropriate protection over the over the
root area which it always has been
outlined but that we possibly
strengthened that with conditions that
we ensure there are no bearing surfaces
to protect those mr. Jeffrey has already
identified that's a mechanism we've used
before and so with that as a condition
I'm proposing that we support this
application sorry the contract contra
North's recommendation I'm looking for a
second I thought I already had proposed
it yielding wouldn't quite clear John
and if you're happy proposed in case the
kettle's willing to defer to you and him
to second I'm happy for either you to I
will Bob the chairman of the council so
cast the kettle is proposing granting of
the application and canceled the
fielding is seconding that proposal we
are happy without so we'll go through
the boat although we do check we can we
do the usual please thank you before
gonna bow before we're actually about
the the reasons for granting the
application and a set of draft
conditions
yeah I defer to the traffic conditions
to the planning office yep thank you
just summarizing the conversation then
the reason for approving the scheme is
that the house is in keeping and
well-designed and that the concerns in
respective compact of trees over over
discs over sort of described in the
Austin be frozen comes back harmful
because of the the the condition they're
currently in according to the reports
provided halfway through oh sorry Norman
Collier on us am I still here now yes
we've got you again now thank you
good thank you yeah so um I'll go from
the top again so the reason for
supporting the application is that
members the house is well designed it's
in keeping the site is appropriate for
new development now we've lost you again
David
I was determined probably if we lost him
he can't hear you say that the message
to whether the message will come through
on the chart and so so is my sir
less or my sir what do you divert to you
back again
why don't we just ask lawyer to going
through the draft conditions first as
chair while we wait for David to
unfreeze always USANA is unfrozen I'm
back again sorry for the disconnection
yeah I think that the reason is as I
stated I'm happy to agree that with the
chair in advance in terms of conditions
would propose three years development in
accordance with plans materials to be
submitted to the planning authority
details of service runs development to
take place in accordance with the tree
protection measures described by the
applicant in their reports provision of
details of hard and soft landscaping
within scheme provision of water boats
three bins and electric vehicle charging
points is a councillor I'm used to
disconnection at the moment so thank you
for that right yeah and again agreed
foreign and wording with me canister
kettle I'm just going to mine
OCS one that the pot they the active
accounts Aldo support sustainable
development and I don't know Paul think
that could be something we could add in
for the reasons for the supporting
applications mr. Jeffries maybe has a
comment
yes that's entirely reasonable
councillor kettle take your point that
on balance a number of the policies
within the core strategy support new
housing development within Stratford and
the members have weighed that against
the potential harm through the loss of
trees and down steep EO trees and found
in favor of the application what about
cs9 distinctiveness
yes what members have confirmed that
they're satisfied in respect to cs9 that
it's a high quality development and that
its distinctive and maintains the main
avenue of trees and that who's
beneficial yes agree with her
right so we've had the proposers in a
second for the reasons just mentioned on
the conditions all those in favor of
going against our recommendation to
grant this application please vote and
I'll ask this to collect the vote and we
will vote as we have done before
Thank You chairman councilor Crump on
voting against the proposal to grant
councilor Mills I'm going against the
opponent of the grant yes that's the
fielding no John that's the fielding
fielding for these Thank You counselor
counselor Fleming I'm gonna vote for
their for the proposal Thank You
councillor Henry Saracen vote for the
application to grams thank you cancel it
unit can I just [ __ ] against cancer
your kettle Oh careful careful and play
with the application thank you and
council of rock against the
recommendation 2 grams Thank You
chairman that's four votes four and four
votes against chairman may I make a
comment counselor Junaid says he was
abstaining before we started this one
now she's voting against it no is that
allowed cancer Junod is able to vote
when the officer us for the vote so I've
got no problem with counts the Junod and
I didn't think she said I thought when
cancer June dark she spoke and I'll
bring you in this second it's the JUnit
sorry I don't always in your um but
cancer journeyed indicated she was
against the proposal so
I think that was right but again sorry
cancer is doing it if you want to come
in I want I support what the officer has
put forward and I do not want this
application do not support this
application being done yep thank you so
it's four votes for and forward against
custom vote I will keep my vote the same
and go along ago against the okay
against the proposal to grant the
application
so therefore in my math that makes it
five for review and you're going against
sorry five for against the proposal and
call for a green so the proposal is lost
- is that is that right and now you have
to start again so now somebody has to
propose for refusal to propose I'm
willing to propose this Susan Jeanette
I'm willing to propose refusal on the
grounds that the officer has given in
the report Thank You councillor Janet
looking for a seconder for that proposal
in that mr. chairman Thank You
councillor nails and now we'll we'll go
through the vote to go along with the
officers recommendation to refuse the
application okay thank you thank you
chairman councilor Krunk for councillor
Mills or cuts the fielding okay
against councillor Fleming against
cancer hunter Seraphin again
councillor JUnit
well thank you you know councillor
Quetzal like I thought against and
councillor Rock thanks to the rock for
Thank You chairman again that's four
votes four votes against right and again
I will use my cast and votes to go along
with my in favor of refusing this
application as per cancer journey its
proposal and seconded by Councillor
Mills
so therefore the application is this
committee reduces so I need to put a
light on so I can't see what I'm doing
that it's gone rather dark we chose to
refuse application 19 / 0 3 3 4 3 thank
you for that right our next item on the
agenda the meeting times start tons of
meetings of this committee for 2021 we
started at 6 o'clock today which is the
same time as Planning Committee I
previously start at 6:15 because
previous members of Planning Committee
Bay or planning East as before we're
unable to get here quarter past 6:00
until I could pass next week so I'm
proposing that to be consistent with
planning committee I we start at 6
o'clock it's given that a clear message
to members of the public we're starting
at the same time and I think it's very
sensible so on proposing that we can I
like large committee meetings
hello sorry I lost myself and committee
be committee be meeting start at 6
o'clock
looking for seconder please agree
this gentleman knows it second all those
in favor
I think chair well that would have to do
generate usual procedure move right will
do the roll call with with this sorry
this that's okay Thank You chairman
counselor crumbles
that's the fielding counselor Fleming
for necessary for canceled unit Custer
cats all right tell if I can call and
castle rock castle rock fall
so unanimous chairman thank you thank
you
starting at six not call remember so six
o'clock it's just going to be recorded
on the web our website it's live
yeah so I will bring the meat into an
end with my gavel and normally at this
time the night I would say have a safe
journey home so I hope that still
applies now and thank you for your
forbearance and a thorough discussion of
all the issues and again I'll just
apologize for coming across is slightly
grumpy I'll try and be I do better next
time thank you very much Thank You chair
thank you everybody thank you and good
night